programming throwdown episode 87 typescript take it away jason hey everyone welcome back awesome friday episode you know friday's a short month and uh it's always tough for us to uh Hey everyone, welcome back. Awesome Friday episode. Friday's a short month and it's always tough for us to plan. Sorry, not Friday. February's a short month. It's always hard for us to plan February. It's also my birth month. That doesn't help. Happy birthday! Thank you. I'm born right in the middle of the month.
programming throwdown episode 87 typescript take it away jason hey everyone welcome back awesome friday episode you know friday's a short month and uh it's always tough for us to uh Hey everyone, welcome back. Awesome Friday episode. Friday's a short month and it's always tough for us to plan. Sorry, not Friday. February's a short month. It's always hard for us to plan February. It's also my birth month. That doesn't help. Happy birthday! Thank you. I'm born right in the middle of the month.|||Programming Throwdown 第 87 期：TypeScript，交给你了，杰森。大家好，欢迎回来。非常棒的周五节目，你知道，周五是个短月份，而且……呃，对我们来说，规划总是很难……抱歉，不是周五。二月是个短月份。规划二月对我们来说总是很难。这也是我的生日月份。这可没帮上忙。生日快乐！谢谢。我正好出生在月中。
Oh, we missed it. there's a wrench into things um but uh yeah here we are and hopefully we'll get this out to you uh right before uh before before march wait but that means you have to do it before friday of february that's correct because friday is march okay is friday march or saturday march friday friday that's a challenge we'll see if we can do it. We're going to do it. All right. So I'm actually going to talk about micro kitchens. Now, this is maybe very specific to Silicon Valley.
Oh, we missed it. there's a wrench into things um but uh yeah here we are and hopefully we'll get this out to you uh right before uh before before march wait but that means you have to do it before friday of february that's correct because friday is march okay is friday march or saturday march friday friday that's a challenge we'll see if we can do it. We're going to do it. All right. So I'm actually going to talk about micro kitchens. Now, this is maybe very specific to Silicon Valley.|||哦，我们错过了。这中间出了点乱子，嗯……但是……好吧，我们现在在这儿，希望我们能在三月之前……呃，在三月之前把这期节目发给你们。等等，但这意味着你必须在二月的周五之前完成。没错，因为周五就是三月了。好吧，周五是三月还是周六是三月？周五，周五。这倒是个挑战，我们看看能不能做到。我们一定会做到的。好的。所以，我实际上要讲的是微型厨房。现在，这可能非常符合硅谷的特色。
I don't know. No, I take it back. I worked at other places that had this. But a micro kitchen is basically a place where you can go that has food. It could be either a vending machine or or it could be free food um and micro kitchens are dangerous and so i tend to go through these cycles where um it's sort of like waking up uh like like like i'm waking up from a dream i guess or something but i realize that i'm just eating like four candy bars a day or something insane oh i'm like okay this has to stop and so i'll
I don't know. No, I take it back. I worked at other places that had this. But a micro kitchen is basically a place where you can go that has food. It could be either a vending machine or or it could be free food um and micro kitchens are dangerous and so i tend to go through these cycles where um it's sort of like waking up uh like like like i'm waking up from a dream i guess or something but i realize that i'm just eating like four candy bars a day or something insane oh i'm like okay this has to stop and so i'll|||我不知道。不，我收回刚才的话。我曾在其他有这种设施的地方工作过。但微型厨房基本上就是一个你可以去拿食物的地方。它既可以是自动售货机，也可以是免费食物，嗯……微型厨房是很危险的，所以我往往会经历这样的周期：嗯……这有点像醒来，嗯……就像我从梦中醒来一样，我猜或者别的什么，但我意识到我一天居然吃四根巧克力棒之类的疯狂东西，哦，我想，好吧，这不能再继续下去了，所以我就会
like just stop eating any snacks and uh um and that will last a while and then all of a sudden i'm like wait a minute i just ate four candy bars today wait a minute i've been eating four candy bars for the past month and then it's like oh i have to start all over again do you have this or are you have you been able to like regulate yourself so so i do know what you're talking about but i'll clarify i think you mean that at a place of work like at your office near where your desk is so not like a cafeteria downstairs but like the place near like each floor in an office building or something will typically have maybe this is a uh people who are in college i guess it's not really like this but like you have a vending machine like on your floor or in your sort of desk area and they'll
like just stop eating any snacks and awesomely um and that will last a while and then all of a sudden i'm like wait a minute i just ate four candy bars today wait a minute i've been eating four candy bars for the past month and then it's like oh i have to start all over again do you have this or are you have you been able to like regulate yourself so so i do know what you're talking about but i'll clarify i think you mean that at a place of work like at your office near where your desk is so not like a cafeteria downstairs but like the place near like each floor in an office building or something will typically have maybe this is a uh people who are in college i guess it's not really like this but like you have a vending machine like on your floor or in your sort of desk area and they'll|||比如干脆停止吃任何零食，呃……这种情况会持续一段时间，然后突然间我又想：等等，我今天刚吃了四根巧克力棒；等等，我过去一个月一直在吃四根巧克力棒。然后就变成：哦，我又得重新开始了。你有过这种经历吗？还是说你能够自我克制？所以，我确实知道你在说什么，但我澄清一下，我想你指的是在工作场所，比如在办公室你办公桌附近的地方。所以不是楼下的食堂，而是办公楼每一层附近之类的地方，通常会有……也许这是……呃，上大学的人，我猜其实不太一样，但就像你在自己的楼层或办公桌区域有一个自动售货机，他们会
have yeah like some vending machine and there's typically refrigerators and a microwave and almost every place has coffee or a water cooler in coffee and so like gathering around the water cooler i thought you were going to go with a gathering around the water cooler story but uh no i mean the thing is for me is like uh you know i'll hit compile and then maybe 30 seconds there's 30 seconds and uh i'll find myself going and getting a chocolate in that 30 seconds i'll come come back. I'll hit compile again. And usually, depending on the kitchen, I mean, some micro kitchens will have just kind of pretty small, like little bite sized snacks. And yeah, you just it's just a habit.
have yeah like some vending machine and there's typically refrigerators and a microwave and almost every place has coffee or a water cooler in coffee and so like gathering around the water cooler i thought you were going to go with a gathering around the water cooler story but uh no i mean the thing is for me is like uh you know i'll hit compile and then maybe 30 seconds there's 30 seconds and uh i'll find myself going and getting a chocolate in that 30 seconds i'll come come back. I'll hit compile again. And usually, depending on the kitchen, I mean, some micro kitchens will have just kind of pretty small, like little bite sized snacks. And yeah, you just it's just a habit.|||有，对吧，比如一些自动售货机，通常还有冰箱和微波炉，几乎每个地方都有咖啡或饮水机和咖啡。所以，就像聚在饮水机旁边……我还以为你要讲一个围着饮水机聊天八卦的故事呢，但是……呃，没有，我的意思是，对 lubricants 来说……呃，你知道，我点击编译，然后大约有30秒的时间，有30秒，呃，我会发现自己在拿这30秒的时间去拿一块巧克力，然后回来。我再次点击编译。通常，取决于厨房的情况，我的意思是，一些微型厨房只会提供相当小巧的、一口大小的零食。是的，你只是……这只是一种习惯。
You get in this habit of like, I have this little delay. So let me go eat snacks. I have this. Yeah. My latest thing now is i generally don't eat that many meals at work like i won't have a really big lunch or anything like that um so what i will do is my new rule now is it has to be perishable so that means yogurt or a cheese stick or you know like i guess a glass of milk or know, a smoothie or something like that.
You get in this habit of like, I have this little delay. So let me go eat snacks. I have this. Yeah. My latest thing now is i generally don't eat that many meals at work like i won't have a really big lunch or anything like that um so what i will do is my new rule now is it has to be perishable so that means yogurt or a cheese stick or you know like i guess a glass of milk or know, a smoothie or something like that.|||你养成了这样的习惯：我这里有个小延迟，所以让我去吃点零食吧。我有这个习惯。是的。我现在的最新做法是，我在工作时通常不会吃那么多正餐，比如我不会吃一顿非常丰盛的午餐之类的，嗯……所以我要做的是，我现在的铁律是它必须是易腐烂的，这意味着酸奶或奶酪棒，或者你知道的，比如我猜一杯牛奶，或者奶昔之类的东西。
Or a brownie, or a cookie. No, those things, well, the ones that we have anyway are, like, kind of like those bagged up ones. As long as it's in the bag, you could leave it for a year, it'd be fine. But anything's perishable if you open it up and leave it out. Yeah, that doesn't count. That's totally cheating. That's like eating lobster on lent or something. So, no, no, it has to be something that, you know, would rot in a couple of days if it was at room temperature. That's my new rule.
Or a brownie, or a cookie. No, those things, well, the ones that we have anyway are, like, kind of like those bagged up ones. As long as it's in the bag, you could leave it for a year, it'd be fine. But anything's perishable if you open it up and leave it out. Yeah, that doesn't count. That's totally cheating. That's like eating lobster on lent or something. So, no, no, it has to be something that, you know, would rot in a couple of days if it was at room temperature. That's my new rule.|||或者布朗尼蛋糕，或者饼干。不，那些东西，嗯，我们有的那些无论如何都是那种袋装的。只要它在袋子里，你放上一年也没事。但任何东西只要你打开它并放在外面，它就会变质。对，那不算。那完全是在作弊。这就好比在大斋期间吃龙虾一样。所以，不，不，它必须是那种，你知道的，如果放在室温下几天就会腐烂的东西。这就是我的新规则。
And so I'm trying to see if that's going to work out. Interesting. Yeah, the temptation of getting lots of snacks when they're freely available and sodas is a real thing, especially if they're free. I feel as humans rationalizing and dealing with free is just very difficult. And so anytime I've been somewhere where even when I've worked in places where there wasn't free food, but someone might bring in like, oh, here's cookies or here's whatever, here's a cake for someone's birthday and it's like always someone's birthday like having access to that yeah you really got to be careful because they're as you pointed out i think what happens is you eat it while you're not thinking about it
And so I'm trying to see if that's going to work out. Interesting. Yeah, the temptation of getting lots of snacks when they're freely available and sodas is a real thing, especially if they're free. I feel as humans rationalizing and dealing with free is just very difficult. And so anytime I've been somewhere where even when I've worked in places where there wasn't free food, but someone might bring in like, oh, here's cookies or here's whatever, here's a cake for someone's birthday and it's like always someone's birthday like having access to that yeah you really got to be careful because they're as you pointed out i think what happens is you eat it while you're not thinking about it|||所以我正在尝试看这是否行得通。有意思。是的，当有大量免费零食和苏打水唾手可得时，这种诱惑是真实存在的，尤其是它们还是免费的。我觉得作为人类，去理性地看待和处理“免费”的东西实在是太难了。所以每当我身处某些地方——甚至当我曾在没有免费食物的地方工作时——可能会有人带进来，比如，哦，这里有饼干，或者这里有别的什么，这里有某人的生日蛋糕，而且感觉好像总是在过生日——就像能够接触到这些东西一样，是的，你真的必须小心，因为正如你所指出的，我觉得发生的情况是，你在不知不觉中就把它们吃掉了。
like i'll take it back to my desk and eat it while i'm working or coding and then that's the worst kind of thing because you're not thoughtful about eating it you're not sitting there thinking like i'm consuming this you're just sort of like putting food in your mouth while doing something else and it's really easy to over consume yeah and it's a total waste like you're not really getting anything out of it and um so i mean right now there's probably two camps of people there's the vast majority of people who have never seen me and then there's the few people who are are like you know what is this person talking about because i'm a total beanpole if you've ever seen me i'm very skinny person but um it turns out this this people might
like i'll take it back to my desk and eat it while i'm working or coding and then that's the worst kind of thing because you're not thoughtful about eating it you're not sitting there thinking like i'm consuming this you're just sort of like putting food in your mouth while doing something else and it's really easy to over consume yeah and it's a total waste like you're not really getting anything out of it and um so i mean right now there's probably two camps of people there's the vast majority of people who have never seen me and then there's the few people who are are like you know what is this person talking about because i'm a total beanpole if you've ever seen me i'm very skinny person but um it turns out this this people might|||比如我会把它带回办公桌，边工作或边写代码边吃，然后这绝对是最糟糕的一种情况，因为你对吃东西并没有过脑子，你不是坐在那里想着我在消耗这些东西，你只是在做别的事情的同时把食物塞进嘴里，这非常容易导致过度摄入。是的，而且这完全是浪费，因为你并没有真正从中得到什么，而且……所以我的意思是，现在可能存在两大阵营：绝大多数从来没见过我的人，以及少数觉得“这人在胡说八道什么”的人，因为如果你们见过我，就会知道我完全是个竹竿，我非常瘦。但是……事实证明，这些人可能
not know this but if you're like regardless of your frame um in fact if you have a thin frame it actually has a more dramatic effect if you eat a lot and you have a thin frame you really don't feel well and uh so it's important for everyone to eat healthy. I feel like this became a PSA. Like, eat healthy, and I feel like you're about to say exercise. Yeah, that's right. Eat healthy, exercise. I don't know, what are the other ones?
not know this but if you're like regardless of your frame um in fact if you have a thin frame it actually has a more dramatic effect if you eat a lot and you have a thin frame you really don't feel well and uh so it's important for everyone to eat healthy. I feel like this became a PSA. Like, eat healthy, and I feel like you're about to say exercise. Yeah, that's right. Eat healthy, exercise. I don't know, what are the other ones?|||不知道这一点，但如果你……不管你的体型如何，嗯……事实上，如果你体型偏瘦，其实它的负面效果会更戏剧化：如果你吃得很多而且体型偏瘦，你真的会感觉很不舒服，呃……所以对每个人来说，吃得健康是很重要的。我觉得这都快成公益广告了。比如，吃得健康，而且我觉得你接下来就要说去锻炼了。对，没错了。吃得健康，多锻炼。我不知道，还有哪些来着？
Love yourself. We're just going to, the whole thing from now on is going to be a self-help episode. And use TypeScript. One of those things is true uh yeah all right well talking starting in on the news i'll go first so i i know that people have written in and reminded us of things we've talked about in past podcasts and thinking about the kinds of things we've talked about it's been one of those recurring but not directly related things that we've discussed on the podcast has been space travel because let's face it rockets are cool uh and space is cool
Love yourself. We're just going to, the whole thing from now on is going to be a self-help episode. And use TypeScript. One of those things is true uh yeah all right well talking starting in on the news i'll go first so i i know that people have written in and reminded us of things we've talked about in past podcasts and thinking about the kinds of things we've talked about it's been one of those recurring but not directly related things that we've discussed on the podcast has been space travel because let's face it rockets are cool uh and space is cool|||爱自己。我们接下来整期节目都要变成心灵鸡汤节目了。还要使用 TypeScript。其中有一件事是真的。呃，好吧，开始进入新闻环节，我先来。所以……我知道有人写信提醒我们，我们在过去的播客中谈论过的一些事情，回想一下我们谈论过的那类事情，我们在播客中讨论过的一个反复出现但并非直接相关的话题就是太空旅行，因为让我们面对现实吧，火箭很酷，呃，太空也很酷。
and so this uh last week virgin galactic uh went to space which they had traveled to space before on their newly designed spaceship two um and well uh it has a reversion a revision of spaceship one so now we version our rockets or our spaceships so spaceship two had gotten to space a little while ago a couple weeks ago a month ago a couple months ago and they went again and this time instead of just the two pilots the pilot and the co-pilot they also brought a passenger now the spaceship is supposed to hold I believe it was six passengers but they only brought one And it was actually a trained space person. Like, I think they were previously an astronaut. So it was like a pilot test or something.
and so this uh last week virgin galactic uh went to space which they had traveled to space before on their newly designed spaceship two um and well uh it has a reversion a revision of spaceship one so now we version our rockets or our spaceships so spaceship two had gotten to space a little while ago a couple weeks ago a month ago a couple months ago and they went again and this time instead of just the two pilots the pilot and the co-pilot they also brought a passenger now the spaceship is supposed to hold I believe it was six passengers but they only brought one And it was actually a trained space person. Like, I think they were previously an astronaut. So it was like a pilot test or something.|||所以，呃，上周维珍银河公司飞向了太空，他们之前曾乘坐他们重新设计的“太空船二号”去过太空，嗯……而且，呃，它是“太空船一号”的一个升级版本，所以现在我们给我们的火箭或飞船也编上了版本号。所以“太空船二号”在不久前——几周前、一个月前、几个月前——曾去过太空，而他们又去了一次。这一次，除了两名飞行员（正驾驶和副驾驶）之外，他们还带了一名乘客。现在这艘飞船本应容纳，我相信是六名乘客，但他们只带了一名。而且那其实是一个受过训练的太空专业人士。比如，我记得他以前是一名宇航员。所以这就像是一次飞行员测试之类的。
Yeah. So they were there to test out the systems and the restraints and stuff and make sure everything kind of worked. But they did, you know, sort of go in again. But I mean, this means they're getting closer. They're getting ready to, you know, actually take sort of paying passengers, I guess is what you would say. And it's just kind of exciting because I know we've talked about this in the past about when everyone was anticipating it. And I think it was very during the, what was that? The X Prize for going to space.
Yeah. So they were there to test out the systems and the restraints and stuff and make sure everything kind of worked. But they did, you know, sort of go in again. But I mean, this means they're getting closer. They're getting ready to, you know, actually take sort of paying passengers, I guess is what you would say. And it's just kind of exciting because I know we've talked about this in the past about when everyone was anticipating it. And I think it was very during the, what was that? The X Prize for going to space.|||是的。所以他们去那里是为了测试系统、约束装置等等，并确保一切都能正常运转。但他们确实，你知道，再次进入了太空。我的意思是，这意味着他们离目标更近了。他们正准备，你知道的，实际上开始搭载付费乘客，我想你会这么说。这让人有点兴奋，因为我知道我们过去曾讨论过这一点，当时每个人都在期待它。而且我认为这非常契合那个……那叫什么来着？太空X大奖（X Prize）。
I have to be careful not to say SpaceX. The X Prize for going to space. Is that where the name came from? SpaceX from the X Prize? Not that i know of but it might be i don't i don't know um we'd have to look it up um the but people got really excited about buying tickets to go to space and there was people who went up to their national space station and it was you know for a while talked about all the time and then i feel like i guess if you see that hype curve i guess it's the typical stuff everybody got really excited it, and then we actually just tried to make progress on it.
I have to be careful not to say SpaceX. The X Prize for going to space. Is that where the name came from? SpaceX from the X Prize? Not that i know of but it might be i don't i don't know um we'd have to look it up um the but people got really excited about buying tickets to go to space and there was people who went up to their national space station and it was you know for a while talked about all the time and then i feel like i guess if you see that hype curve i guess it's the typical stuff everybody got really excited it, and then we actually just tried to make progress on it.|||我得小心别说成 SpaceX。去太空的 X 大奖。SpaceX 的名字是不是就来源于此？SpaceX 来自 X 大奖？据我所知不是，但也有可能，我不知道，嗯……我们得查一下。嗯……但是人们对购买去太空的船票感到非常兴奋，有的人甚至上到了他们国家的空间站，你知道的，有一段时间到处都在谈论这个。然后我觉得，如果你看到那个炒作曲线（Hype curve），我想这就是典型的情况：每个人都非常兴奋，然后我们才真正开始努力在这上面取得进展。
And now I think actual real progress is being made towards that end again, where hopefully we'll start to see it soon. It'll still be really expensive, but hopefully it'll actually start happening pretty soon. And it seems like Virgin Galactic is on the verge of making it happen. Really cool. So SpaceX and XPRIZE are not related. It's just a coincidence. But the Virgin Galactic, so what is it? What's the trajectory like? I mean, does it
And now I think actual real progress is being made towards that end again, where hopefully we'll start to see it soon. It'll still be really expensive, but hopefully it'll actually start happening pretty soon. And it seems like Virgin Galactic is on the verge of making it happen. Really cool. So SpaceX and XPRIZE are not related. It's just a coincidence. But the Virgin Galactic, so what is it? What's the trajectory like? I mean, does it|||而现在我认为朝着这个目标又有了切实的实质性进展，希望我们很快就能看到它。它仍然会非常昂贵，但希望它真的很快就会开始发生。而且看起来维珍银河正处于将其实现的边缘。真的很酷。所以 SpaceX 和 XPRIZE 没有关系。这只是一个巧合。但是维珍银河，那么它是什么？它的轨迹是怎样的？我的意思是，它会
go straight up like a rocket? Or is it like an airplane that can just keep going up? Or how does it work? No, I mean, it's a rocket. So it has a big airplane with a really big wing that takes it to a very high altitude. And then the smaller spaceship detaches and turns its rocket on, shoots out from underneath it and goes into roughly a parabola. And the peak of the parabola is past the, is it the, oh man, I always forget the Carmen line or something well oh okay yeah but there's like a line that's generally considered uh i think it's the carmen line yeah uh is the line where people talk about space which is actually a funny other thing which i won't get into because i don't have notes prepared for it but there's a difference of reaching what the u.s considers reaching space and what the eu considers reaching space aren't at the same altitude really yeah because space it's a gradient of atmosphere right yeah there's no like sign you know earth ends here and it's not so so there's particles of air um like in if you were to go in like really far out the moon still be particles of air but there would be just very few
go straight up like a rocket? Or is it like an airplane that can just keep going up? Or how does it work? No, I mean, it's a rocket. So it has a big airplane with a really big wing that takes it to a very high altitude. And then the smaller spaceship detaches and turns its rocket on, shoots out from underneath it and goes into roughly a parabola. And the peak of the parabola is past the, is it the, oh man, I always forget the Carmen line or something well oh okay yeah but there's like a line that's generally considered uh i think it's the carmen line yeah uh is the line where people talk about space which is actually a funny other thing which i won't get into because i don't have notes prepared for it but there's a difference of reaching what the u.s considers reaching space and what the eu considers reaching space aren't at the same altitude really yeah because space it's a gradient of atmosphere right yeah there's no like sign you know earth ends here and it's not so so there's particles of air um like in if you were to go in like really far out the moon still be particles of air but there would be just very few|||像火箭一样直冲云霄吗？还是像一架可以一直往上飞的飞机？或者它是怎么运作的？不，我的意思是，它是一枚火箭。所以它有一架带有超大机翼的大型飞机，把飞船带到非常高的高空。然后较小的飞船脱离并启动火箭，从飞机下方冲出去，大致进入一条抛物线轨迹。抛物线的顶点超过了……是那个……天哪，我总是忘掉卡门线（Kármán line）什么的。哦，好吧，是的，但是有一条线通常被认为……我认为是卡门线，对，呃……是人们谈论太空的分界线。实际上，这还有一件有趣的事，我就不展开讲了，因为我没有准备相关笔记：美国认为的到达太空与欧盟认为的到达太空，这两者的高度并不一样。真的吗？是的，因为太空是大气层的渐变，对吧？是的，没有什么标志牌说“地球到此结束”，并不是这样的。所以空气粒子……嗯，就像如果你去到非常遥远的地方，月球上仍然会有空气粒子，只不过非常稀少罢了。
so i was reading about this recently somebody just did a study or whatever and i guess there are particles at some density of particles per cubic meter at the moon of of hydrogen atoms from earth so earth's atmosphere is more and more diffuse all the way up to the moon someone else pointed out that it's like i want to say i'm gonna mess up like 120 orders of magnitude or something so the difference is so extreme that it's not clear that it's meaningful like what does it mean to be meaningful but whatever the moral of the story is there's a gradient right it's uh very close to earth atmosphere very dense at at the moon, basically non-existent, but somewhere, you know, in between, there's varying levels.
so i was reading about this recently somebody just did a study or whatever and i guess there are particles at some density of particles per cubic meter at the moon of of hydrogen atoms from earth so earth's atmosphere is more and more diffuse all the way up to the moon someone else pointed out that it's like i want to say i'm gonna mess up like 120 orders of magnitude or something so the difference is so extreme that it's not clear that it's meaningful like what does it mean to be meaningful but whatever the moral of the story is there's a gradient right it's uh very close to earth atmosphere very dense at at the moon, basically non-existent, but somewhere, you know, in between, there's varying levels.|||所以我最近在读这方面的内容，有人刚刚做了一项研究什么的，我猜月球上每立方米含有一定浓度的来自地球的氢原子粒子，所以地球的大气层一直延伸到月球，变得越来越稀薄。另一个人指出，这就像是——我想说，我可能会把数量级弄错，比如120个数量级左右——所以这种差异极端到不清楚它是否有意义，比如“有意义”到底意味着什么。但无论如何，这个故事的寓意是：存在一个梯度，对吧？它离地球大气层很近时非常浓厚；到了月球时基本上不存在；但在两者之间的某处，你知道的，存在着不同的浓度级别。
So most people would say, you know, satellites are orbiting in space, but some satellites orbit much lower than other satellites, very drastically different altitudes that satellites can orbit at. So yeah, cool. Anyways, yeah, so they made it to just space or at least recognized by the u.s as having done so and i think the last episode or a few episodes ago we looked this up and it was 100k for one ticket oh so it's it's still pretty pricey but yeah i mean if they cut it down to even 10k i mean that could be reasonable i mean it's it's still a lot of money for a short experience but yeah i mean it's something that's doable. Obviously, if they get it down to a thousand, then it'd be very. Oh, yeah.
So most people would say, you know, satellites are orbiting in space, but some satellites orbit much lower than other satellites, very drastically different altitudes that satellites can orbit at. So yeah, cool. Anyways, yeah, so they made it to just space or at least recognized by the u.s as having done so and i think the last episode or a few episodes ago we looked this up and it was 100k for one ticket oh so it's it's still pretty pricey but yeah i mean if they cut it down to even 10k i mean that could be reasonable i mean it's it's still a lot of money for a short experience but yeah i mean it's something that's doable. Obviously, if they get it down to a thousand, then it'd be very. Oh, yeah.|||所以大多数人会说，你知道，卫星在太空中运行，但有些卫星的轨道比其他卫星低得多，卫星运行的高度差异非常巨大。所以，是的，很酷。不管怎样，是的，他们成功到达了太空的边缘，或者至少被美国承认做到了这一点。而且我记得在上期或前几期的节目中我们查过，一张票要10万美元。哦，所以它仍然相当昂贵。不过，是的，我的意思是，如果他们把价格降到哪怕1万美元，那也算合理吧。我的意思是，对于短暂的体验来说，这仍然是一大笔钱，但是的，我的意思是，这是可以做到的事情。很显然，如果他们能把价格降到1000美元，那就会非常……哦，是的。
I mean, then it's like, well, yeah. Yeah. So but to answer your question, I mean, it's a parabola. You at the peak, you know, get up, you see Earth's curvature. You have experienced weightlessness for a short amount of time, but it doesn't complete an orbit of Earth or anything. So it's still suborbital okay so i mean that would be a cool thing to me like being able to go around a full orbit that that seems pretty awesome but i don't know how far away that is that's obviously much
I mean, then it's like, well, yeah. Yeah. So but to answer your question, I mean, it's a parabola. You at the peak, you know, get up, you see Earth's curvature. You have experienced weightlessness for a short amount of time, but it doesn't complete an orbit of Earth or anything. So it's still suborbital okay so i mean that would be a cool thing to me like being able to go around a full orbit that that seems pretty awesome but i don't know how far away that is that's obviously much|||我的意思是，那就像是……好吧，确实。是的。所以为了回答你的问题，我的意思是，这是一条抛物线。你在顶点处，你知道的，升上去，你会看到地球的曲率。你体验了短时间的失重，但它并没有完成对地球的轨道运行之类的。所以它仍然是亚轨道的。好吧，我的意思是，对我来说那会是一件很酷的事，比如能够绕地球完整运行一周，那听起来相当棒，但我不知道那还有多远，那显然要
even more difficult than what they're doing now so i feel like uh i mean it can't be that much more difficult right because when you the further out get, the less energy you need to go further, right? I mean, I guess that's hard for me to know. Well, but it's a... So this is... I feel like we should just play some more Kerbal space program, whatever. Yeah, that's right.
even more difficult than what they're doing now so i feel like uh i mean it can't be that much more difficult right because when you the further out get, the less energy you need to go further, right? I mean, I guess that's hard for me to know. Well, but it's a... So this is... I feel like we should just play some more Kerbal space program, whatever. Yeah, that's right.|||比他们现在做的困难得多得多，所以我觉得……呃，我的意思是，应该不会难太多吧？因为当你去到更远的地方时，你需要去得更远所需的能量就越少，对吧？我的意思是，这对我来说可能很难知道。不过，这是一个……所以这是……我觉得我们应该再去玩玩《坎巴拉太空计划》（Kerbal Space Program）之类的。是的，没错。
I just need to go play some more Kerbal. But I think... So the issue is to get the extra height, though, the extra speed you need to be able to reach orbit and the extra height though the extra speed you need and you know to to be able to reach orbit and extra the height reach orbital velocities the the extra uh fuel you burn up there you have to carry with you which means you have to carry more fuel to get that fuel up there but then you need more fuel to carry you know it's like a compounding thing uh so yeah that makes sense i mean it's
I just need to go play some more Kerbal. But I think... So the issue is to get the extra height, though, the extra speed you need to be able to reach orbit and the extra height though the extra speed you need and you know to to be able to reach orbit and extra the height reach orbital velocities the the extra uh fuel you burn up there you have to carry with you which means you have to carry more fuel to get that fuel up there but then you need more fuel to carry you know it's like a compounding thing uh so yeah that makes sense i mean it's|||我只需要去多玩一会儿《坎巴拉》。但我想……所以问题在于，要获得额外的高度，不过，为了能够进入轨道，你需要额外的速度和额外的高度，不过你需要额外的速度，你知道的，为了能够达到轨道速度和额外的高度，你在那里燃烧的额外的……呃，燃料，你必须随身携带，这意味着你必须携带更多的燃料来把那些燃料运送到高空，但随后你需要更多的燃料来运送……你知道的，这就像是一个复合累加的事情，呃……所以是的，这说得通，我的意思是，它
doable obviously like we get to outer space with satellites and stuff. But I don't think it's easy. And I think... And it becomes even more expensive. Yeah. And more dangerous. Yeah, makes sense. All right, my article is Hot Reload All the Things.
doable obviously like we get to outer space with satellites and stuff. But I don't think it's easy. And I think... And it becomes even more expensive. Yeah. And more dangerous. Yeah, makes sense. All right, my article is Hot Reload All the Things.|||显然是可行的，就像我们用卫星等设备进入外太空一样。但我不认为这很容易。而且我认为……而且它变得更加昂贵。是的。而且更危险。是的，有道理。好的，我的文章是《热重载万物》（Hot Reload All the Things）。
So this is about something I think is pretty fascinating. Basically, so just to give a little background here. So there's people who do the front-end web server in Node.js. So what that means is you go to a website, you go to http://mywebsite.com slash foo, and then there's a handler that has to process that foo and and do something you know return back some data or what have you and now it might go and communicate to even more servers and things like that but usually that or not usually but many times that front-end server is going to be running node.js then your your browser so the code that's executing on the browser is also running
So this is about something I think is pretty fascinating. Basically, so just to give a little background here. So there's people who do the front-end web server in Node.js. So what that means is you go to a website, you go to http://mywebsite.com slash foo, and then there's a handler that has to process that foo and and do something you know return back some data or what have you and now it might go and communicate to even more servers and things like that but usually that or not usually but many times that front-end server is going to be running node.js then your your browser so the code that's executing on the browser is also running|||所以这篇文章讲的是我认为非常迷人的一件事。基本上，先做个简单的背景介绍。有些人使用 Node.js 来编写前端 Web 服务器。这意味着什么呢？当你访问一个网站，比如访问 `http://mywebsite.com/foo`，然后就会有一个处理程序来处理这个 `foo` 请求，并做一些事情，比如返回一些数据或诸如此类的内容。现在它可能会去与更多的服务器之类的东西进行通信，但通常——或者不一定是通常，但在很多情况下——那个前端服务器会运行 Node.js。然后你的浏览器——在浏览器上执行的代码也在运行
javascript it's not running node.js but it's running just regular javascript right and so what this lets you do is you can actually hot reload the server or the client and what hot reload means is every time you save a file, that takes effect immediately. So imagine, you know, you're you have an endpoint, it's supposed to return your name, and it only returns your first name. So you say, oops, you might have to say, okay, change the code, you know, add your last name, you know, compile it, maybe like, deploy it, like run a server maybe have to push it to another machine or something like that and then on the client you have to like hit refresh right well you don't do any of that basically you save the file and it's
javascript it's not running node.js but it's running just regular javascript right and so what this lets you do is you can actually hot reload the server or the client and what hot reload means is every time you save a file, that takes effect immediately. So imagine, you know, you're you have an endpoint, it's supposed to return your name, and it only returns your first name. So you say, oops, you might have to say, okay, change the code, you know, add your last name, you know, compile it, maybe like, deploy it, like run a server maybe have to push it to another machine or something like that and then on the client you have to like hit refresh right well you don't do any of that basically you save the file and it's|||JavaScript。它运行的不是 Node.js，而是普通的 JavaScript，对吧？因此，这让你能够做到的是，你可以对服务器或客户端进行“热重载”（Hot Reload）。而热重载的意思是，每次你保存一个文件，它就会立即生效。所以想象一下，你知道的，你有一个 API 端点，它应该返回你的名字，但它只返回了你的名（First name）。所以你说，哎呀，你可能得说，好吧，修改代码，你知道的，加上你的姓（Last name），你知道的，编译它，也许像这样，部署它，比如运行服务器，可能还得把它推送到另一台机器或类似的东西上，然后在客户端你还得点击刷新，对吧？好吧，你根本不用做那些，基本上你只要保存文件，它
just it notices that you've saved it and it hits reload automatically and you just see the change right away it's's really cool. So, you know, when I was trying to get, you know, trying to get a new TypeScript project off the ground, I found this website and it just feels like visceral. It just feels so cool when you get this set up. It's a lot of work. It's way more cumbersome than I would have liked. But once I did finally get it working, it's so cool that you just basically, you just have two screens. One screen has your website, the other screen has your ID. And every time you hit save, like you just, you're seeing it kind of build itself. It feels almost like very like futuristic.
just it notices that you've saved it and it hits reload automatically and you just see the change right away it's's really cool. So, you know, when I was trying to get, you, trying to get a new TypeScript project off the ground, I found this website and it just feels like visceral. It just feels so cool when you get this set up. It's a lot of work. It's way more cumbersome than I would have liked. But once I did finally get it working, it's so cool that you just basically, you just have two screens. One screen has your website, the other screen has your ID. And every time you hit save, like you just, you're seeing it kind of build itself. It feels almost like very like futuristic.|||就会注意到你已经保存了它，并会自动触发重载，然后你就会立刻看到变化。这真的很酷。所以，你知道的，当我试图启动、试图让一个新的 TypeScript 项目落地时，我发现了这个网站，那种感觉简直太直观了。当你把这个环境搭建好时，感觉真的酷毙了。这需要做很多工作。它比我希望的要繁琐得多。但一旦我最终让它运行起来，那种感觉真是太酷了：基本上，你只需要有两个屏幕。一个屏幕显示你的网站，另一个屏幕显示你的 IDE。每次你按下保存，就像是……你看着它自己构建自己。感觉几乎非常具有未来感。
And so check this out. It pretty long pretty detailed it'll take some time to get through um but once you have it it's a very very cool framework to build a site nice uh so i looked it up i'm not sure how accurate it is but it looks like it's a factor of 32 to go from suborbital to uh orbital velocity oh that sounds like a problem so i might be misreading it we could stay here and compute the math and i guess there's a lot of assumptions to be made but this article i found says it's about a 32 fold like a 32x difference okay that makes it way harder i think i mean so as it is now though it doesn't circumnavigate the earth but it does maybe what a third of it or something no no no i mean it's no no it just like pops up and pops right back down oh so this is even in a different state i mean how many miles
And so check this out. It pretty long pretty detailed it'll take some time to get through um but once you have it it's a very very cool framework to build a site nice uh so i looked it up i'm not sure how accurate it is but it looks like it's a factor of 32 to go from suborbital to uh orbital velocity oh that sounds like a problem so i might be misreading it we could stay here and compute the math and i guess there's a lot of assumptions to be made but this article i found says it's about a 32 fold like a 32x difference okay that makes it way harder i think i mean so as it is now though it doesn't circumnavigate the earth but it does maybe what a third of it or something no no no i mean it's no no it just like pops up and pops right back down oh so this is even in a different state i mean how many miles|||所以去看看这个吧。它相当长也相当详细，读完需要花点时间，嗯……但一旦你掌握了它，用它来构建网站就是一个非常非常酷的框架。不错。呃，所以我查了一下，我不确定它有多准确，但看起来从亚轨道加速到轨道速度，速度差了大约 32 倍。哦，听起来这像是个问题，所以可能是我看错了。我们可以留在这里计算一下数学，我猜这里有很多假设需要做，但我找到的这篇文章说大约是 32 倍，也就是 32 倍的差异。好吧，这让它变得难得多，我想。我的意思是，虽然现在的情况是，它并不环绕地球飞行，但它可能完成了三分之一左右的航程？不，不，不，我的意思是，它不是……不，不，它就像是弹射上去然后马上又弹射下来。哦，所以这完全是另一种状态，我是说，有多少英里？
are we talking about so this is the thing that always confuses me too so we were just talking about uh space this the carmen line is about 100 kilometers up yeah about 62 miles but if you think about 62 miles along the surface of the earth that's actually not far at all oh i see right so like going 62 miles is like nothing like i commute 10 miles to work um yeah each day right so like going 62 miles at 60 miles an hour this is one hour driving on the highway uh california is a big state so we actually don't get very far if we drive for an hour um but that far up and And you don't have to fly horizontally, right? You can fly in sort of a circle, a spiral up. Yeah, right.
are we talking about so this is the thing that always confuses me too so we were just talking about uh space this the carmen line is about 100 kilometers up yeah about 62 miles but if you think about 62 miles along the surface of the earth that's actually not far at all oh i see right so like going 62 miles is like nothing like i commute 10 miles to work um yeah each day right so like going 62 miles at 60 miles an hour this is one hour driving on the highway uh california is a big state so we actually don't get very far if we drive for an hour um but that far up and And you don't have to fly horizontally, right? You can fly in sort of a circle, a spiral up. Yeah, right.|||我们到底在谈论什么？所以这也是一直让我感到困惑的事情。我们刚才在谈论……呃，太空，这个卡门线大约在 100 公里高空，对吧，大约 62 英里。但如果你想想沿着地球表面走 62 英里，其实一点也不远。哦，我明白了，对吧？所以，走 62 英里简直不算什么，就像我每天通勤去上班要开 10 英里一样，嗯……对吧？所以以每小时 60 英里的速度开 62 英里，就是在高速公路上开一个小时的车。加州是个大州，所以如果我们开车开一个小时，其实也走不了多远。嗯……但是飞那么高，而且你不需要水平飞行，对吧？你可以以某种圆圈或螺旋上升的方式飞行。是的，没错。
So actually, no. So Earth's atmosphere is sort of thin if you compare it to sort of the circumference of the Earth. Okay, that makes sense. Yeah, which is why you hear astronauts talk about this thin blue line is like where all of Earth's life lives. Because like Earth itself is really big compared to how thick the atmosphere is. Or the like part we consider substantial. This is totally, totally off topic. But I'm just kind of surprised that I guess other than digging for oil, there's not really that much.
So actually, no. So Earth's atmosphere is sort of thin if you compare it to sort of the circumference of the Earth. Okay, that makes sense. Yeah, which is why you hear astronauts talk about this thin blue line is like where all of Earth's life lives. Because like Earth itself is really big compared to how thick the atmosphere is. Or the like part we consider substantial. This is totally, totally off topic. But I'm just kind of surprised that I guess other than digging for oil, there's not really that much.|||所以实际上，并不是这样的。因此，如果你把地球大气层与地球的周长相比，它其实算相当薄的。好吧，这说得通。是的，这就是为什么你会听到宇航员谈论这条“细细的蓝色线条”，这就是地球上所有生命居住的地方。因为与大气层的厚度相比，地球本身真的非常巨大。或者说我们认为结实的那部分。这完全、完全跑题了。但我只是有点惊讶，我猜除了开采石油之外，其实并没有太多……
Like there's not really that much use for the entire kind of core of the earth i mean there's use but not that we do anything about i didn't enjoy the effects of gravity i mean well sure but like we haven't found a way to really uh i guess my i mean i guess it's just rock and dirt at the end of the day. So it says the deepest hole ever dug was 12 kilometers, but Earth's radius is 6,378 kilometers. What? Wait, really? Yeah.
Like there's not really that much use for the entire kind of core of the earth i mean there's use but not that we do anything about i didn't enjoy the effects of gravity i mean well sure but like we haven't found a way to really uh i guess my i mean i guess it's just rock and dirt at the end of the day. So says the deepest hole ever dug was 12 kilometers, but Earth's radius is 6,378 kilometers. What? Wait, really? Yeah.|||比如对于整个地球内核来说，其实并没有太大的用处。我的意思是，是有用处，但并不是我们能做些什么的。我不喜欢引力带来的影响。我的意思是，当然，但我们还没有找到真正的方法来……我想我的意思是，归根结底它不过是岩石和泥土罢了。因此，文章说人类掘出的最深洞穴是 12 公里，但地球的半径是 6,378 公里。什么？等等，真的吗？对。
6,000 kilometers is the radius? Yeah. Oh, yeah, that makes sense. Now that I think about it. I mean, now that I think about the circumference you know yeah okay well this is completely off topic but yeah it just turns out for me i have the same realization a while ago when i was thinking about this being always thinking oh i kind of like space i'm into space and then putting these numbers in perspective it's like yeah i never really thought
6,000 kilometers is the radius? Yeah. Oh, yeah, that makes sense. Now that I think about it. I mean, now that I think about the circumference you know yeah okay well this is completely off topic but yeah it just turns out for me i have the same realization a while ago when i was thinking about this being always thinking oh i kind of like space i'm into space and then putting these numbers in perspective it's like yeah i never really thought|||6,000 公里是半径？对。哦，对，这说得通。现在我想想。我是说，现在想想周长，你知道的，对。好吧，这完全跑题了。不过是的，对我来说也是如此，不久前当我思考这个问题时，我也有过同样的感悟：我总是想着“我挺喜欢太空的，我对太空很感兴趣”，然后把这些数字放到宏观视角下去看，就会发现：是的，我以前从来没有真正想过
about it like this yeah like it's really hard work to go that 100 kilometers up like way way way way harder than just like traveling horizontally 100 kilometers right just like in phasm unfathomably harder but then it makes sense like climbing a staircase is way harder than going for a walk i mean it's kind of wild but like uh you know with the right with the right kind of solar panels couldn't you take energy that was just going from the sun, that was just going to be wasted in the ocean, and light up like an entire surface below the surface that you dig out? And you could have a whole continent underground that's just supported by light that's being harnessed.
about it like this yeah like it's really hard work to go that 100 kilometers up like way way way way harder than just like traveling horizontally 100 kilometers right just like in phasm unfathomably harder but then it makes sense like climbing a staircase is way harder than going for a walk i mean it's kind of wild but like uh you know with the right with the right kind of solar panels couldn't you take energy that was just going from the sun, that was just going to be wasted in the ocean, and light up like an entire surface below the surface that you dig out? And you could have a whole continent underground that's just supported by light that's being harnessed.|||会是这样。是的，就像去到那 100 公里高空真的是一件极其艰难的工作——比单纯水平移动 100 公里要难上成千上万倍，对吧？就像……不可思议地难。但随后这也说得通，爬楼梯比散步要难得多。我的意思是，这有点疯狂，但是……呃，你知道的，如果拥有合适的高效太阳能电池板，你难道不能收集那些原本要照射进海洋并被浪费掉的太阳能，然后去点亮你挖出的地表之下的整个表面吗？这样你就可以在地下拥有一个完全靠被收集的光能支撑的整块大陆了。
That would have been just going into the ocean. I feel like you're going to spoil our book of the show and you're going to tell us this is the, uh, this is what the book you read was. No, no. I mean, that's, that would be a great book. A great sci-fi book. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, all that kind of stuff. Okay. Well onto my next post, my next link. Uh, so mine was, was i guess keep i must be on like a kick recently i don't know what it is anyways my next post is uh how flight radar 24 works so flight radar 24 is a website you can go to that will show you many of the or at least i think all of the commercial airlines that are flying around like where they are in real time all over the country um okay and
That would have been just going into the ocean. I feel like you're going to spoil our book of the show and you're going to tell us this is the, uh, this is what the book you read was. No, no. I mean, that's, that would be a great book. A great sci-fi book. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, all that kind of stuff. Okay. Well onto my next post, my next link. Uh, so mine was, was i guess keep i must be on like a kick recently i don't know what it is anyways my next post is uh how flight radar 24 works so flight radar 24 is a website you can go to that will show you many of the or at least i think all of the commercial airlines that are flying around like where they are in real time all over the country um okay and|||那些光本来是要照进海洋的。我觉得你这是要剧透我们节目的推荐书目，你接下来就要告诉我们这就是……呃，这就是你看的那本书的内容吧。不，不。我的意思是，那会是一本好书。一本很棒的科幻小说。是的。是的。我的意思是，诸如此类的事情。好吧，进入我的下一篇帖子，我的下一个链接。呃，所以我的……我猜我最近一定迷上了什么东西，我也不知道是什么。不管怎样，我的下一篇帖子是：呃，Flightradar24 是如何工作的。所以 Flightradar24 是一个你可以访问的网站，它会向你展示许多——或者至少我认为是所有的——正在全国各地飞行的商业航班，以及它们在全国范围内的实时位置，嗯……好吧，而且
it's kind of cool actually uh over much of the world it'll show you sort of where you are so if you just go to flight radar 24 and you can uh you know just sort of like see i did this the other day we're just like toggling around looking at various airplanes if you're into like aviation you can see more about uh you know like the specific tail numbers and things um is it run by the government or something no so that's the interesting part so it's not and uh and i was actually trying to find the map but uh what happens is is that all commercial uh air well there's more nuance but i'm not and i not a pilot, so I don't exactly understand the distinctions they were trying to make when I was reading up for this story. But the requirement for many airplanes is that they have to have on a transponder that is used so that other things in the sky don't hit them so if you have two airplanes they each have these transponders these radio emitters and then they say hey i'm airplane with this metadata this information
it's kind of cool actually uh over much of the world it'll show you sort of where you are so if you just go to flight radar 24 and you can uh you know just sort of like see i did this the other day we're just like toggling around looking at various airplanes if you're into like aviation you can see more about uh you know like the specific tail numbers and things is it run by the government or something no so that's the interesting part so it's not and uh and i was actually trying to find the map but uh what happens is is that all commercial uh air well there's more nuance but i'm not and i not a pilot, so I don't exactly understand the distinctions they were trying to make when I was reading up for this story. But the requirement for many airplanes is that they have to have on a transponder that is used so that other things in the sky don't hit them so if you have two airplanes they each have these transponders these radio emitters and then they say hey i'm airplane with this metadata this information|||它其实挺酷的。呃，在世界大部分地区，它能显示出你的大致位置，所以如果你访问 Flightradar24，你就可以……呃，你知道的，就像我前几天做的那样，我们只是四处切换看着各种飞机。如果你喜欢航空，你可以看到更多关于……你知道的，比如具体的尾翼编号之类的信息。它是政府运营的还是什么的？不，这正是最有趣的部分：它不是。而且……呃，我其实一直在找地图，但……发生的情况是，所有的商业航空——嗯，这其中还有更多细微的差别，但我不是，我也不是飞行员，所以我并不是很懂我在为这个故事做背景阅读时他们试图做出的那些区别。但对许多飞机的要求是，它们必须配备一个应答机（Transponder），这样天空中其他东西就不会撞到它们。所以如果有两架飞机，它们都有这些应答机、这些无线电发射器，然后它们会说：“嘿，我是带有这个元数据、这个信息的飞机，
and i'm at this location and they send that out to other airplanes can listen um and okay what happens is with some uh it turns out over time has gotten cheaper, with some cheap radio, software-defined radio, you can listen for those beacons. So if you live anywhere near an airport or anywhere where airplanes sort of fly overhead, you can listen for these little chirps, these little bursts of data that the planes send out. And by doing that, which is what this FlightRadar24 website,
and i'm at this location and they send that out to other airplanes can listen um and okay what happens is with some uh it turns out over time has gotten cheaper, with some cheap radio, software-defined radio, you can listen for those beacons. So if you live anywhere near an airport or anywhere where airplanes sort of fly overhead, you can listen for these little chirps, these little bursts of data that the planes send out. And by doing that, which is what this FlightRadar24 website,|||我在这个位置”，并把这些信息广播出去，其他飞机就可以听到。嗯，好吧，发生的情况是，随着时间的推移，某些……呃，结果证明这变得更便宜了。利用某些廉价的无线电、软件定义无线电（SDR），你可以监听这些信标。因此，如果你住在机场附近，或者住在飞机经常从头顶飞过的任何地方，你就可以听到这些微弱的“啁啾”声，也就是飞机发出的那些微小的数据爆发信号。通过这种方式——这也是这个 Flightradar24 网站所做的——
and there are other ones with varying degrees of how open or APIs you want or all that kind of stuff. But basically, they establish a network of people, amateurs, I guess, who have these radios that know where you are. Oh, I guess you don't have to know where you are for the first part, but just listen for these chirps. So for instance, I live near an airport in the Bay Area. And an airplane flies over i could have one of these and anytime an airplane's in range i could use my radio receiver to listen for this the burst of data that comes from all the airplanes and then i could make a little little map on my you know raspberry pi and there's already people who developed all this that would show me like
and there are other ones with varying degrees of how open or APIs you want or all that kind of stuff. But basically, they establish a network of people, amateurs, I guess, who have these radios that know where you are. Oh, I guess you don't have to know where you are for the first part, but just listen for these chirps. For instance, I live near an airport in the Bay Area. And an airplane flies over i could have one of these and anytime an airplane's in range i could use my radio receiver to listen for this the burst of data that comes from all the airplanes and then i could make a little little map on my you know raspberry pi and there's already people who developed all this that would show me like|||还有其他一些网站，它们对开放程度或 API 的需求程度各有不同，诸如此类。但基本上，他们建立了一个由人们组成的网络，我猜是业余爱好者，他们拥有这些能……呃，知道你在哪里的无线电设备。哦，我猜在前半部分你不需要知道你在哪里，只需监听这些“啁啾”声即可。例如，我住在湾区的一个机场附近。如果有飞机飞过，我可以拥有其中一台设备，每当有飞机在范围内，我就可以用我的无线电接收器去监听来自所有飞机的这种数据爆发信号，然后我就可以在我的（你知道的）树莓派（Raspberry Pi）上制作一张小地图。而且已经有人开发好了这一切，可以向我展示，比如
all of the airplanes I can currently hear where they're at, what their current heading is. And sort of if I sent that data to this website, they could aggregate it from lots and lots of sources and have it, you know, kind of all over the world, which is what they do. And so that's pretty nice. And then what they also are able to do is, so apparently some of the airplanes don't say I'm at this location, like they don't give their coordinates. But if you know where you are and you know where other people are, then you can sort of correlate those reports together and figure out where the airplane is and where it's going by sort of just listening to its beacon over time and saying, yeah, that makes sense to the triangulation. So other people are able to,
all of the airplanes I can currently hear where they're at, what their current heading is. And sort of if I sent that data to this website, they could aggregate it from lots and lots of sources and have it, you know, kind of all over the world, which is what they do. And so that's pretty nice. And then what they also are able to do is, so apparently some of the airplanes don't say I'm at this location, like they don't give their coordinates. But if you know where you are and you know where other people are, then you can sort of correlate those reports together and figure out where the airplane is and where it's going by sort of just listening to its beacon over time and saying, yeah, that makes sense to the triangulation. So other people are able to,|||我当前能听到的所有飞机的位置在哪里，它们当前的航向是什么。如果我将这些数据发送给这个网站，他们就可以从成千上万个来源中聚合这些数据，让它覆盖全球各地，这就是他们正在做的事情。所以这真的很棒。然后他们还能做到的是：显然，有些飞机并不说“我在这个位置”，也就是说它们不提供自己的坐标。但如果你知道自己的位置，又知道其他接收站的位置，那么你就可以将这些报告关联起来，通过随着时间推移监听飞机的信标，弄清楚飞机在哪里以及它要去哪里，并且说：是的，这符合三角测量的原理。所以其他人也能够……
I think it's called like multilateralization or something. They call it. And so they're able to do that. And I thought that was kind of cool for a couple of reasons. One, I kind of didn't know that that's how that worked. It's kind of interesting to say oh wow all these airplanes flying around are just saying where they are all the time
I think it's called like multilateralization or something. They call it. And so they're able to do that. And I thought that was kind of cool for a couple of reasons. One, I kind of didn't know that that's how that worked. It's kind of interesting to say oh wow all these airplanes flying around are just saying where they are all the time|||我想这被称为多点定位（Multilateration）或类似的名字，他们是这么叫的。所以他们能够做到这一点。我之所以觉得这挺酷，有几个原因。第一，我以前基本上不知道它是这样运作的。这就很有意思：哦，哇，所有这些在空中飞来飞去的飞机竟然一直在广播它们的位置！
i was you kind of have this feeling when you go to the airport that planes are places but you never it's always just sort of like are they here or are they not here but being able to pull up now next time i go i'm looking forward to this actually going and figuring out what flight what airplane my flight is going to be and then figuring out where it is and actually being able to see sort of like on a map like oh it's i'm in california and it's in nevada headed towards me oh it's almost here good um i don't know that it will help me oh that's just i never put that together but you're right you can you could look at your own plane that's getting to you and see if it's at the airport yet. Or like, so when my, so I have kids, and when we go to the airport to pick up family,
i was you kind of have this feeling when you go to the airport that planes are places but you never it's always just sort of like are they here or are they not here but being able to pull up now next time i go i'm looking forward to this actually going and figuring out what flight what airplane my flight is going to be and then figuring out where it is and actually being able to see sort of like on a map like oh it's i'm in california and it's in nevada headed towards me oh it's almost here good um i don't know that it will help me oh that's just i never put that together but you're right you could look at your own plane that's getting to you and see if it's at the airport yet. Or like, so when my, so I have kids, and when we go to the airport to pick up family,|||当你去机场时，你会有这样一种感觉：飞机总归在某些地方，但你从来……它总是处于一种“它们在这里”还是“它们不在这里”的状态。但现在能够把它调出来，下次我去的时候，我真的很期待去查清楚我的航班将是哪架飞机，然后找出它在哪里，并且能够真正在地图上看到，比如：哦，我在加州，它在内华达州，正朝我飞来，哦，它快到了，太好了。嗯……我不知道这能不能帮到我……哦，就是这样，我以前从没把这两者联系起来，但你是对的，你可以查看正在飞向你的那架飞机，看看它是否已经到达机场了。或者就像——所以当我的……我有孩子，当我们去机场接家人时，
we're always like, we get to the airport, it's like, oh, is that their plane? Is that their plane? Yeah, we're not going to have to play that game anymore. No, I'm just going to pull up the thing and be like, oh, they're playing, yep, there it is. It's the one on approach right now. You're going to be that dad.
we're always like, we get to the airport, it's like, oh, is that their plane? Is that their plane? Yeah, we're not going to have to play that game anymore. No, I'm just going to pull up the thing and be like, oh, their plane, yep, there it is. It's the one on approach right now. You're going to be that dad.|||我们总是这样：一到机场就忍不住问，“哦，那是他们的飞机吗？那是他们的飞机吗？”是的，我们再也不用玩那个猜谜游戏了。不，我只要打开那个软件就会说：“哦，他们的飞机，没错，就是那个。它现在正在进近（Approach）呢。”你又要当那种爸爸了。
Yeah, well. You're going to be that dad who's like, nope, I found the plane with my ssh connection in the airport no uh well so so the other cool one of the things is that this uh flight radar 24 i guess has varying levels of subscription i only learned about this i haven't messed around with it a lot but if you buy one of these raspberry pi radio things and set it up you actually get access to like a higher level of subscription in return for contributing your data so um that's another cool thing but the
Yeah, well. You're going to be that dad who's like, nope, I found the plane with my ssh connection in the airport no uh well so so the other cool one of the things is that this uh flight radar 24 i guess has varying levels of subscription i only learned about this i haven't messed around with it a lot but if you buy one of these raspberry pi radio things and set it up you actually get access to like a higher level of subscription in return for contributing your data so um that's another cool thing but the|||是啊，好吧。你会成为那种爸爸，逢人便说：“不，我在机场用我的 SSH 连接找到了那架飞机……”没有，呃……好吧，所以……另一个很酷的事情是，这个……呃，Flightradar24 我猜有不同等级的订阅。我刚了解这个，我还没怎么深入折腾过。但如果你买一个这种树莓派无线电设备并把它设置好，你实际上就可以获得更高等级的订阅权限，以此来回报你贡献的数据。所以，嗯……这是另一个很酷的地方。但
software defined radio stuff is also pretty cool that this is uh something i always read about but it's it's beginning to become like kind of interesting and all the different things that you can use to uh instead of having a traditional radio where you would have a knob to tune or whatever you you're able to have fpgas i think is how it works uh i'm not actually a big radio person i feel like it's always one of those things one day i wanted to learn more about like ham radio and how that works but basically you're able to control a lot of the parameters of the radio from your computer and do things like tune into the frequencies where the transponders are transmitting. Whereas if you just went and bought a normal radio off the shelf, like an FM radio or AM radio, they're going to have a very specific limited set of frequencies they listen to and also the fm or am the frequency modulation or amplitude modulation they're going to assume a way of decoding those signals so
software defined radio stuff is also pretty cool that this is uh something i always read about but it's it's beginning to become like kind of interesting and all the different things that you can use to uh instead of having a traditional radio where you would have a knob to tune or whatever you you're able to have fpgas i think is how it works i'm not actually a big radio person i feel like it's always one of those things one day i wanted to learn more about like ham radio and how that works but basically you're able to control a lot of the parameters of the radio from your computer and do things like tune into the frequencies where the transponders are transmitting. Whereas if you just went and bought a normal radio off the shelf, like an FM radio or AM radio, they're going to have a very specific limited set of frequencies they listen to and also the fm or am the frequency modulation or amplitude modulation they're going to assume a way of decoding those signals so|||软件定义无线电（SDR）这东西也相当酷，这是……呃，我一直有在读相关的东西，但它正变得越来越有意思。你可以用各种不同的东西来……呃，取代传统无线电——在传统无线电中，你得靠旋钮来调台什么的——你现在能够使用 FPGA（现场可编程门阵列），我想它的原理大概是这样。其实我并不是一个精通无线电的人，我觉得这总是那种“总有一天我想更多了解业余无线电（Ham radio）及其工作原理”的事情。但基本上，你能够从电脑上控制无线电的许多参数，并做一些诸如调谐到应答机正在发射的频率之类的事情。而如果你只是去货架上买个普通的收音机，比如调频（FM）收音机或调幅（AM）收音机，它们只能监听非常特定且有限的一组频率，而且对于 FM 或 AM（频率调制或幅度调制），它们会预设一种解码这些信号的方式，所以
instead the software defined radio allows you to have a broader set of you know spectrums you're listening to tune into a different place uh and then you know sort of write your own decoders built into the the sort of chain where it could do, you know, frequency encoded messages where it hops around and uses them as some sort of pattern. It could just be anything, I guess. And different radio systems use different patterns, including this one that airplanes use. That's awesome. Yeah, it's I think at some point, though, you have to be careful with the legality, right? Like I know all the things you buy, even just headphones and stuff.
instead the software defined radio allows you to have a broader set of you know spectrums you're listening to tune into a different place uh and then you know sort of write your own decoders built into the the sort of chain where it could do, you, frequency encoded messages where it hops around and uses them as some sort of pattern. It could just be anything, I guess. And different radio systems use different patterns, including this one that airplanes use. That's awesome. Yeah, it's I think at some point, though, you have to be careful with the legality, right? Like I know all the things you buy, even just headphones and stuff.|||相反，软件定义无线电允许你监听更广阔的频谱范围，去调谐到不同的地方，呃……然后你可以，你知道的，编写自己的解码器，并将其构建到处理链中，使其能够处理……你知道的，跳频编码信息（Frequency encoded messages），它会跳来跳去，并将其作为某种模式使用。我想这可以是什么都行。不同的无线电系统使用不同的模式，包括飞机使用的这种模式。太棒了。是的，不过我认为在某些时候，你必须注意合法性问题，对吧？就像我知道你买的所有东西，甚至只是耳机之类的东西。
They have this warning, you know, this won't emit frequencies other than what it's designed for, blah, blah, blah. Yeah. So you're only listening. So you're only receiving. So as far as I know, I'm not an expert, but I mean, you don't even need to mount an antenna. So having something that listens to radio waves in your house isn't going to cause a problem so as long as you don't transmit if you start transmitting yeah I think you could get sort of like that could be a problem so don't transmit unless you know what you're doing and I don't so don't ask me but listening I think listening is fine I mean if you're just listening I mean just absorbing some signal I can't see why that would be there would be any issue now there is some stuff about like I think what I've said is fine i mean if you're just listening i mean just absorbing some signal i can't see why that
They have this warning, you know, this won't emit frequencies other than what it's designed for, blah, blah, blah. Yeah. So you're only listening. So you're only receiving. So as far as I know, I'm not an expert, but I mean, you don't even need to mount an antenna. So having something that listens to radio waves in your house isn't going to cause a problem so as long as you don't transmit if you start transmitting yeah I think you could get sort of like that could be a problem so don't transmit unless you know what you're doing and I don't so don't ask me but listening I think listening is fine I mean if you're just listening i mean just absorbing some signal i can't see why that would be there would be any issue now there is some stuff about like i think what i've said is fine i mean if you're just listening i mean just absorbing some signal i can't see why that|||它们都有这样的警告，你知道的：“本设备不会发射超出其设计用途的频率，等等等等。”是的。所以你只是在监听。所以你只是在接收。据我所知——我不是专家——我的意思是，你甚至不需要安装天线。所以在家里放一个监听无线电波的设备是不会出问题的，只要你不发射信号。如果你开始发射信号，是的，我觉得你可能会陷入某种……那可能会是个问题。所以除非你知道自己在做什么，否则不要发射信号，而我并不知道，所以别问我。但监听，我觉得监听是没问题的。我的意思是，如果你只是在监听，也就是仅仅吸收一些信号，我看不出这会有什么问题。现在有一些关于……我觉得我刚才说的挺好的，我的意思是，如果你只是在监听，也就是仅仅吸收一些信号，我看不出这会有
would be there would be any issue now there is some stuff about like i think what i've said about listening also works for uh flights like uh you know i don't know like military flights and stuff i think also have it i saw some discussion about this but the nuances escaped me so i won't try to recite them here i'm sure they're all encrypted at that point, right? Well, but again, you can listen for the transponding signal's presence and figure out where it is. And the fact that it's encrypted seems like it might be meaningful. Oh, sure. Yeah, so but varying.
would be there would be any issue now there is some stuff about like i think what i've said about listening also works for uh flights like uh you know i don't know like military flights and stuff i think also have it i saw some discussion about this but the nuances escaped me so i won't try to recite them here i'm sure they're all encrypted at that point, right? Well, but again, you can listen for the transponding signal's presence and figure out where it is. And the fact that it's encrypted seems like it might be meaningful. Oh, sure. Yeah, so but varying.|||什么问题。现在有一些关于……我想我刚才关于监听所说的话同样适用于……呃，航班，比如……呃，你知道的，我不知道，比如军用航班之类的，我想它们也有。我看到过一些关于这方面的讨论，但其中的细微差别我记不清了，所以我不会在这里试着复述它们。我敢肯定，到了那种程度它们全都是加密的，对吧？嗯，话虽如此，你仍然可以监听应答信号的存在并弄清楚它在哪里。而且它是加密的这一事实，似乎可能很有意义。哦，当然。是的，所以情况有所不同。
Yeah, that makes sense. So I don't know, again, not an expert, not a lawyer. Talk to someone who is. But I know that various of these websites and aggregators have different rules for what they sort of will and won't post information for. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I mean, if you are getting a signal at a location that's encrypted and just happens to be over some military base and you're posting on the Internet, yeah, that seems like you can get in trouble. Well, you should make your own decisions about that, I guess. Yeah, I mean, sure, make your own decision,
Yeah, that makes sense. So I don't know, again, not an expert, not a lawyer. Talk to someone who is. But I know that various of these websites and aggregators have different rules for what they sort of will and won't post information for. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, i mean, if you are getting a signal at a location that's encrypted and just happens to be over some military base and you're posting on the Internet, yeah, that seems like you can get in trouble. Well, you should make your own decisions about that, I guess. Yeah, I mean, sure, make your own decision,|||是的，这说得通. 所以我不知道，再次声明，我不是专家，也不是律师。去问问专业人士吧。但我知道，这些网站和聚合商中的各种网站对于它们会发布和不会发布什么信息都有不同的规则。是的，这说得通。是的，我的意思是，如果你在某个地点接收到了一个加密信号，而该地点恰好位于某处军事基地上空，并且你把它发到了网上，是的，那看起来你确实会惹上麻烦。嗯，我想你应该自己对此做出决定。是的，我的意思是，当然，自己做决定，
but I'm going to make it for you. That's a bad idea. Called it. Speaking of bad ideas, don't write crazy articles about your AI. That's not a good idea. So there's some folks at this research lab. They created this AI that could basically, you would give it the start of a conversation
but I'm going to make it for you. That's a bad idea. Called it. Speaking of bad ideas, don't write crazy articles about your AI. That's not a good idea. So there's some folks at this research lab. They created this AI that could basically, you would give it the start of a conversation|||但我来替你做决定吧：这是个糟糕的主意。被我言中了。说到糟糕的主意，不要写关于你的 AI 的疯狂文章。那不是个好主意。所以，这个研究实验室里有一些人。他们创造了这个 AI，基本上，只要你给它一段对话的开端
or the start of a monologue, and it would write more paragraphs of that monologue. So for example example you could say you know john f kennedy you know was assassinated on such and such a day and then it would actually just write sentences that sounded like they were sort of world building or just describing that event so they would just say you, the grass was a certain way, there was a gunman, he shot John F. Kennedy, blah, blah, blah. And they claimed that it was so realistic that they didn't want to release the source code.
or the start of a monologue, and it would write more paragraphs of that monologue. For example example you could say you know john f kennedy you know was assassinated on such and such a day and then it would actually just write sentences that sounded like they were sort of world building or just describing that event so they would just say you, the grass was a certain way, there was a gunman, he shot John F. Kennedy, blah, blah, blah. And they claimed that it was so realistic that they didn't want to release the source code.|||或者独白的开端，它就能接着写出那段独白的更多段落。例如，你可以说，你知道，约翰·F·肯尼迪，你知道的，在某年某月某日被暗杀，然后它实际上就会写出一些句子，听起来像是某种世界构建（World building）或者是对该事件的描述，所以它们会直接说：草是某种样子的，有一个枪手，他向约翰·F·肯尼迪开枪了，等等等等。而且他们声称这个 AI 太逼真了，以至于他们不想发布源代码。
Or no, they actually released the source code, but they didn't want to release the trained model. Or the corpus. Yeah, or the input data that they had um but i believe the input data was just common crawl so it's publicly accessible i don't really understand but maybe they did some pre-processing either way most scientists kind of agree that it's not that big a deal it's not that big an accomplishment um It didn't, you know, it generated phrases that more or less, you know, could be considered grammatically correct. But the, you know, anyone with some common sense
或者没有，其实他们发布了源代码，但他们不想发布训练好的模型。或者语料库。是的，还有他们拥有的输入数据，嗯，不过我相信输入数据只是Common Crawl，所以是公开访问的，我其实不太理解，但也许他们做了一些预处理。不管怎样，大多数科学家都认为这没什么大不了的，这不是什么了不起的成就，嗯。它并没有，你知道的，它生成的短语多多少少，你知道的，可以被认为是语法正确的。但是，你知道的，任何有一点常识的人
reasoning could see some serious flaws in, you know, the semantics of what it was writing. You know, it's just, it's, I would say it's novel in that the syntax looks correct. And so it might confuse other AI algorithms. But yeah, I mean, if you read some of these, you'll know right away that this isn't normal. Nonetheless, they said, we're not going to show anyone this model because we're afraid that people will just
推理能力的人都能看出它所写内容的语义上有一些严重的缺陷。你知道的，它就是，我觉得它的新颖之处在于语法看起来是正确的。所以它可能会迷惑其他AI算法。但是，是的，我的意思是，如果你读了一些这样的东西，你马上就会知道这不正常。尽管如此，他们还是说，我们不打算把这个模型展示给任何人，因为我们担心人们会开始
start generating things that aren't true and everyone else will start believing them and a lot of people in the community found this really funny um so there's this whole reddit post dedicated to making fun of that and i'll put a link to that too and the idea with with this post is there's this data set called MNIST, which is literally a bunch of photographs of digits on postcards. to 111999 View Avenue, and someone takes a picture of those one ones and nines, and there's a whole corpus of that, and so you can recognize different handwritten digits, right? And someone said, oh, I have 99% accuracy in MNIST, and I'm afraid to release it.
开始生成不真实的内容，而其他人也会开始相信它们，社区里的许多人都觉得这真的很有趣，嗯，所以有一个专门用来取笑这件事的Reddit帖子，我也会把那个链接放出来。这个帖子的想法是，有一个叫MNIST的数据集，它实际上就是明信片上的一堆数字照片。寄往111999 View Avenue，有人给那些“1”和“9”拍了张照片，那里有这方面的整个语料库，所以你可以识别不同的手写数字，对吧？然后有人说，哦，我对MNIST有99%的准确率，我不敢把它发布出来。
It's going to cause the singularity, and someone else was posting posting and they were saying, I have 100% accuracy on my model that predicts who died in the Titanic, you know, which already happened. And so this is a bunch of really funny jokes. But and actually, to be fair, I mean, as much grief as they've been getting, the result is pretty cool definitely not believable by you know like anyone who knows anything about the context of the text but but
它会引发奇点，然后另一个人发帖说，我对预测泰坦尼克号上谁死了的模型有100%的准确率，你知道的，这已经发生了。所以这只是一堆非常有趣的笑话。但是，说实话，尽管他们受到了那么多的抱怨，但结果真的很酷，绝对不会被任何对文本背景略知一二的人所相信，但是
still it's actually pretty good accomplishment and so um i think also someone posted in that reddit group just like a recreation of it already um but uh check it out it's pretty funny and uh some pretty interesting reads too yeah i mean there was some discussion about getting into everyone likes to talk about ai ethics and so i maybe that was cool it just didn't seem like this was particularly what needed to get called in that we we gotta make a decision about ai ethics right now because we're there like if they released this whoosh uh good luck you know everybody who has a job as a writer or author like you're you're done we're just gonna make like uh oh that's what i get they'll become a market for ai clones of popular work so
尽管如此，这实际上是一个相当不错的成就，所以，嗯，我觉得也有人在那个Reddit群里发布了它的一个复刻版，嗯，不过去看看吧，挺有意思的，嗯，也有一些挺有趣的可读内容。是的，我的意思是，有一些关于讨论每个人都喜欢谈论的AI伦理的讨论，所以也许这很酷，只是感觉这并不是特别需要被呼吁说我们需要现在就对AI伦理做出决定，因为我们就在那里。就像如果他们发布了这个，呼——祝你好运，你知道的，每一个以写作为生或作为作家的人，你们就完蛋了，我们只会制作像，哦，这就是我得到的，将会出现一个针对流行作品的AI克隆市场，所以
like uh like famously a bunch of authors have not finished their trilogies people will just feed in like the first two books uh george rr martin they'll just feed in all of the all of the books and then out will pop the the end book and so yeah i mean i don't think we're there okay reading a novel if you're okay reading a novel where nothing actually happens then uh yeah go for it wait but that's the same as the first books that's awesome okay i'm a horrible person speaking of books oh man my book of the show my book the show is a super long title but it's also a very short and free book wow it's called how the economic machine works and how it is reflected now. Check this out. It's pretty cool.
比如，像著名的那样，一堆作家没有写完他们的三部曲，人们只会输入前两本书，比如乔治·R·R·马丁，他们只会输入所有的书，然后就会吐出最后一本书，所以，是的，我的意思是，我不认为我们已经到了那个地步。好吧，如果你看一本其实什么也没发生的小说也没关系，那么，好吧，那就去读吧。等等，但那和前几本书一样啊，这太棒了。好吧，我真是个糟糕的人。说到书，哦天哪，我的本期推荐书，我的本期推荐书，书名超级长，但它也是一本非常短且免费的书。哇，它的名字叫《经济机器是如何运行的以及它现在是如何反映的》。来看看这个。这挺酷的。
So the reason why I stumbled upon this book is I was looking at, I was trying to figure out what happens when someone can't fulfill an order. So like in the stock market, you say, oh, I want to sell this stock. And someone else says, like, you know, someone else says at the same time, I want to sell this stock. And someone else says, like, you know, someone else says at the same time, I want to buy this stock. And as long as he's willing to pay more than you're willing to sell it for, you make the transaction, right? You can also short a stock, which, you know, I'm not going to get into it. I'm not even an expert by any means. But basically, the idea is you tell someone, you know, I'm going to buy your stock at, let's say, $60 a month from now.
所以我偶然发现这本书的原因是，我在寻找，我试图弄清楚当有人无法履行订单时会发生什么。比如在股市里，你说，哦，我想卖出这只股票。然后另一个人说，就像，你知道的，另一个人同时说，我想卖出这只股票。然后另一个人说，就像，你知道的，另一个人同时说，我想买入这只股票。只要他愿意支付比你愿意卖出的价格更高的价钱，你们就完成了交易，对吧？你也可以做空股票，你知道的，我不打算深入探讨这个。我绝不是什么专家。但基本上，这个想法是，你告诉某人，你知道的，我打算在一个月后以比方说60美元的价格买你的股票。
And and a person says, OK. And so, you know, even if the stock goes to like $100, you know, that person still promised to sell it to you for 60. And so the higher it goes, the more money you make. But it always surprised me, these things like shorting. What happens if that person just can't fulfill that? What if that person can't pay? They promised to pay you, but what if they literally can't? Because we all know that there's leverage. So there's people who say, oh, I'll buy this for you for $50. And they don't actually have the $50.
然后那个人说，好的。所以，你知道的，即使股票涨到比如100美元，你知道的，那个人仍然承诺以60美元的价格卖给你。所以它涨得越高，你赚的钱就越多。但这总是让我感到惊讶，像做空这样的事情。如果那个人就是无法履约会怎么样？如果那个人付不起钱怎么办？他们承诺付钱给你，但如果他们真的付不起呢？因为我们都知道其中存在杠杆。所以有些人会说，哦，我以50美元帮你买下这个。而他们实际上并没有这50美元。
Like this is actually more common than not. And so with all of this sort of, with all this speculation, like what happens when someone just can't pay? Or it's even worse with commodities. Someone says, like, I'm going to deliver a thousand cows to you to some butcher. And then that person just literally just can't do it for whatever reason. And it turns out the exchanges do a lot more than I thought. So basically, the exchange backs all of these transactions. So if that person promises to buy your stock for $50 and then the stock goes to, let's say, a cent and that person somehow flees the country out or whatever, he somehow gets out of it.
就像这种情况实际上比比皆是。因此，随着所有这些，随着所有这些投机，当有人就是付不出钱时会发生什么？或者在商品交易中情况更糟。有人说，比如，我要给某个屠夫交付一千头牛。然后那个人由于某种原因，字面意思就是做不到。结果证明，交易所做的事情比我想象的要多得多。所以基本上，交易所为所有这些交易提供担保。因此，如果那个人承诺以50美元的价格买你的股票，然后股票跌到，比方说，一美分，而那个人不知怎么逃离了国家或者怎样，他不知怎么摆脱了这件事，
The exchange market itself will still pay you the $50 and it'll just eat that loss. So part of what you're paying when you pay these commissions is basically insurance, because there are transactions that fall through. And in the case of commodities, there's this thing called the cash market, which is just a fancy way of saying people are willing to sell things right away for money. So if someone promised you like a thousand cows, they can't deliver. At any given time time there's someone trying to sell cows for money and the stock market will just pay whatever or sorry the commodity market will just pay whatever it takes to get you those cows and they'll just eat it now of course
交易所市场本身仍然会向你支付50美元，它会自己承担这笔损失。所以当你支付这些佣金时，你所支付的一部分基本上就是保险，因为有些交易会泡汤。而在商品交易的情况下，有一个叫做现货市场的概念，这只是一种高级的说法，意思是人们愿意立刻用钱买卖东西。所以如果有人承诺给你比如一千头牛，但他们无法交付，在任何给定的时间，总有人试图用钱卖牛，而股市就会支付所需的任何代价，或者抱歉，大宗商品市场会支付获得这些牛所需的任何代价，然后他们会自己吃下这个亏。当然啦，
you know people like the person who doesn't pay like their credit is ruined or I don't know how it actually works in that sense. But it just surprised me the degree to which the market actually, you know, will bail people out. And it actually happens more often than you think. But is it not that so I've not looked into this specific thing, but is it not that if you're going through a brokerage or so most people don't access the market or I don't know most the person, an average person not directly involved with this would use a brokerage. And my guess is the brokerage has to be sort of put up money as part of interacting with the exchange. And I know what the brokerage will do in the case like $50 going down to one cent. Like it could happen instantaneously but typically it starts to slide and you get margin called which is basically they say either you
你知道的，像那个不付钱的人，他们的信用就毁了，或者我不知道在这种情况下它实际上是怎么运作的。但这只是让我惊叹于市场实际上会在多大程度上，你知道的，把人们保释出来。而且这种情况发生的频率实际上比你想象的要高。但是，难道不是这样吗——我没有研究过这个具体的事情，但难道不是如果你通过经纪公司或者，所以大多数人不接触市场，或者我不知道大多数人，一个不直接参与其中的普通人会使用经纪公司。而我的猜想是，经纪公司作为与交易所互动的一部分，必须拿出资金。我知道经纪公司在50美元跌到一美分这样的情况下会怎么做。这可能会瞬间发生，但通常它开始下滑，然后你就会收到追加保证金通知，这基本上就是他们说，要么你
need to put more money in or we're going to liquidate your positions and limit the loss because like you said they have to back it so the brokerage would have to back it which means they're going to basically do like a risk assessment and say how much other things do you have in your account and they can just wipe your whole entire account to you know try to cover your position and then they can even you know charge you money so like you said if you were leveraged up and it would move market moved faster then they could liquidate your position then uh you know they could come after you for what's left or whatever and so i imagine that's on them and that
需要投入更多资金，要么我们将清算你的头寸并限制损失，因为就像你说的，他们必须为其提供担保，这意味着他们基本上要做的是风险评估，并说你的账户里还有多少其他东西，他们可以抹去你的整个账户，你知道的，试图覆盖你的头寸，然后他们甚至可以，你知道的，向你收费，所以就像你说的如果你加了杠杆，而市场变动更快，那么他们就可以清算你的头寸，然后，你知道的，他们可以找你索要剩下的钱或者什么的，所以我想这是他们的责任，而这种情况
happens when uh when you have those those kind of like crashes one of the things is like the flash crash is particularly kind of bad because if people freak out and liquidate your position and then the stock goes back up you would have actually not been as bad off as it was when they liquidated you but uh they weren't going to hold they weren't going to be left holding the bags. But I imagined, I don't know, but that the when you directly, you know, communicate with the exchange, which I don't know how that works with, but that you would have to put up some sort of bond, like some sort of money on the side to say, like, hey, here's something that, you know, like you said, insurance, like here's insurance. So if I go belly up on this, that like it'll pay out.
发生在，当你有那些，那种崩溃的时候。其中一件事就像闪崩特别糟糕，因为如果人们惊慌失措并清算你的头寸，然后股票又涨回去了，你其实就不会像他们清算你时那么惨了，但是，嗯，他们可不会一直拿着烂摊子不管。但我猜，我不知道，但是当你直接，你知道的，与交易所沟通时，我不知道这到底是怎么运作的，但你必须提供某种保证金，比如在旁边放一些钱来说，嘿，这里有些东西，你知道的，就像你说的，保险，这里有保险。所以如果我在这上面破产了，这能赔付。
And that could either be sort of money or someone else who would agree to monitor your risk or you know basically be insurance yeah i mean it's basically a hierarchy of insurances like the brokerage is insuring you the the marketplace is ensuring the brokerages so on and so forth but yeah it's it's pretty cool and this And this article kind of explains that whole thing in detail. So if you're into stuff like that, check it out. It's pretty fascinating. So how many pork belly futures did you buy? Isn't that, there's a movie where these people bought,
这要么是某种金钱，要么是同意监控你风险的人，或者你知道的，基本上就是保险。是的，我的意思是，这基本上是一个保险的层级结构——经纪公司在为你保险，市场在为经纪公司保险，诸如此类。但，是的，这挺酷的，而且这篇文章详细解释了整件事。所以如果你对这种事情感兴趣，去看看吧。这相当迷人。那么你买了几手猪腩肉期货呢？难道不是吗，有一部电影，这些人买了，
what was it, Orange Juice. It's actually Florida Orange Juice Futures. What was that movie called? And they totally went bankrupt um i'll have to look it up i think it's trading places is that right or is that a romantic comedy uh it was trading places was that one is it what has eddie murray eddie murphy right oh no that's not it i'll have to look it up later but there's a show where basically it's like a wolf of wall street type thing where these people are riding high.
是什么来着，橙汁。其实是佛罗里达橙汁期货。那部电影叫什么名字？他们彻底破产了，嗯，我得查一下，我觉得是《颠倒乾坤》，是这样吗，还是那是一部浪漫喜剧？嗯，是《颠倒乾坤》吗，里面有艾迪·墨菲，艾迪·墨菲对吧？哦不，不是那个，我待会儿得查一下，但有一部剧，基本上就像《华尔街之狼》那种类型，这些人正处于意气风发的时候。
Yeah, Orange Juice Futures Contracts. Buying frozen concentrated Orange Juice Futures Contracts. Yeah, they're saying it's some part of Trading Places. I don't know if I've ever seen this movie. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. So that's what does the movie in the end. All right. Yeah.
是的，橙汁期货合约。买入冷冻浓缩橙汁期货合约。是的，他们说这是《颠倒乾坤》的一部分。我不知道我有没有看过这部电影。哦，对，对，对。所以这就是电影最后的内容。好吧，是的。
Well, my book of the show is salvation by peter f hamilton um i've recommended books from his other series and standalone ones before this is his newest one so this is the first of what i did check said that it was going to be a trilogy so i've messed that up before but this one did say although now now I'm missing it. Oh, no, now I'm worried. I thought I had checked this right before I did. Oh, well. So I'll just say series just to be safe.
好吧，我的本期推荐书是彼得·F·汉密尔顿的《救赎》，嗯，我以前推荐过他其他系列和独立作品中的书。这是他的最新力作。所以这是我查过的那什么的第1部，说它将是一个三部曲，所以我以前弄错过，但这本书确实说了，不过现在，现在我找不到了。哦不，现在我开始担心了。我以为我在开始之前刚刚查对过。好吧。所以我还是只说系列好了，以防万一。
So this is book one of his newest series. I think it came out in 2018, like pretty recently. But it is a sci-fi book. It's a little different. I'm having just finished the first book, which it's, uh, it's a pretty hefty, hefty book. I listened to it on audible, which I normally do. I want, I'm gonna look it up. I think it was here. I'm going to tell you a number in a minute anyways. Um, but it's a science fiction book and, uh, Oh crap. I just started downloading it. That's not what I wanted
所以这是他最新系列的第一本书。我想它是2018年出版的，挺近的。但这是一本科幻书。有点不一样。我刚刚读完第一本，它，嗯，这是一本相当厚、相当厚的书。我是用Audible听完的，我通常都这么做。我想，我要去查一下。我觉得它就在这里。我一会儿无论如何会告诉你一个数字。嗯，但这是一本科幻书，嗯，哦糟了。我刚开始下载它。这不是我想
to do. No. Okay. No, nevermind. Uh, I'm going to ruin my internet connection uh so the well i already locked my screen and that uh froze my audacity for a bit so we're in good shape uh so this book is uh set in multiple uh kind of time periods um so all in the future all sort of like you know science fiction um but the there's sort of like different timelines being explored. So it'll sort of like jump back and forth between sort of like a future timeline and a past timeline. And I think that was a little different than sort of a lot of his other works. And so I kind of enjoyed it. So like there's some stuff playing like sort of far out, some stuff playing.
做的事。不。好吧。不，没关系。嗯，我会搞砸我的互联网连接的，嗯，好吧，我已经锁定了屏幕，这让我的Audible卡顿了一会儿，所以我们状态还不错。嗯，所以这本书的背景设定在多个，嗯，某种时间段，嗯，所以都是在未来，都是某种，你知道的科幻小说，但是其中探索了某种不同的时间线。所以它会在某种程度上在未来的时间线和过去的时间线之间来回跳跃。我觉得这和他的很多其他作品有点不同。所以我挺喜欢它的。所以就像有些事情发生在，比方说，很遥远的地方，有些事情发生在。
Well, I guess there's no past because like i'm not clear what the current is but the most forwarded timeline and the least most back timeline are are spread pretty far apart um and it's sort of like a detective thing i didn't feel like it focused as much on some of the sort of technology stuff as he's done before but i thought it was a pretty good book it was a little tough i think that's an interesting idea you know like if i guess in one sense like it's not like a back to the future thing where you're worried about influencing the future because you're just reading things that happened but they're happening at different times it's kind of cool yeah so i mean in what plays out in this
好吧，我想没有过去，因为就像我不太清楚现在是什么，但是最前沿的时间线和最后退的时间线，它们相距相当远，嗯，这有点像侦探故事。我觉得它不像他以前那样过多地关注一些技术方面的东西，但我认为这是一本相当不错书。这有点难，我觉得这是一个很有趣的想法，你知道的，就好像，如果在某种意义上，它不像《回到未来》那样，你需要担心影响未来，因为你只是在阅读已经发生的事情，但它们发生在不同的时间，这挺酷的。是的，所以，我的意思是，在这个故事中展开的是，
it's like you're seeing the impact of stuff you're like oh this is the way the world is and they sort of go to the past and say something i'm like oh that's why that's happening um and so i thought that was cool it says it's a trilogy i did see confirmation so yeah it says it's the first book in a trilogy so i did not mess that up very cool um but yeah so salvation you know it's hard judging like the first book because like it does a lot of world building. It's setting it up. But, you know, like if you've read he has other series which are finished. And so the Commonwealth Saga series, I enjoyed a lot. I really like that one. So I'm hopeful that this series is also going to be good.
就像你看到了事物的影响，你会想，哦，世界原来是这样的，然后他们去了过去并说了一些话，我会想，哦，这就是为什么会发生这个，嗯，所以我认为这很酷。上面说这是一部三部曲，我确实看到了确认，所以，是的，它说是三部曲的第一本书，所以我没有弄错，非常酷，嗯，但是，是的，所以《救赎》，你知道的，很难去评价第一本书，因为它做了很多世界构建。它在做铺垫。但是，你知道的，如果你读过他已经完结的其他系列的话。所以《联邦传奇》系列，我非常喜欢。我真的很喜欢那套书。所以我希望这个系列也会很好。
And I thought this was a solid first outing. It didn't really grab me, but I'm hanging in there. I think it's going to be good. Cool. And you can eventually you can watch or listen to the whole trilogy on Audible. This is the second one you said? This is the first one. Oh, first one. Okay.
我觉得这是一个扎实的处女秀。它并没有真正吸引我，但我会坚持下去的。我觉得它会不错的。酷。而且你最终可以，你可以在Audible上观看或收听整个三部曲。你刚才说这是第二本？这是第一本。哦，第一本。好吧。
And so the second one will be out, what, probably next year? Yeah, he's a pretty prolific writer so this one clocks in at 19 hours and 2 minutes so not his longest wow yeah you can check those out on audible you go to audibletrial.com slash programmingthrowdown
所以第二本将在什么时候出来，大概明年吧？是的，他是一位非常多产的作家，所以这本书时长19小时零2分钟，所以不是他最长的。哇，是的，你可以在Audible上查看这些。你访问audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown
that gives us some support for the show you can also follow us on follow us on Patreon, um, patreon.com slash programming throwdown. Um, all patrons get the super fast RSS feed. Thanks to Patreon. Um, and with that, my tool of the show, this is honestly one of my favorite tools of the show ever. Um, it's, it's, it's it's not useful um it's not you know the the most useful tool i've ever put but it's hilarious it's called the sierra death generator um it actually it was it's it has that name because it was originally um just all of the
这为我们的节目提供了一些支持。你也可以在Patreon上关注我们，嗯，patreon.com/programmingthrowdown。嗯，所有赞助者都可以获得超快的RSS源。感谢Patreon。接下来，我的本期推荐工具，这老实说是我有史以来最喜欢的节目工具之一。嗯，它，它，它，它并不是很有用，嗯，它不是，你知道的，我放过的最有用的工具，但它太搞笑了。它叫做Sierra死亡生成器。实际上，它之所以有这个名字，是因为它最初嗯，只是所有的
sierra games if you ever played like king's quest um uh the the um a lot of these point and click adventure games uh I'm drawing a blank right now but um King's Quest is definitely the most popular is like five isn't like Monkey Island something like yeah Monkey Island that's right and so um what this person did is they took uh various various like motifs for those like the death screen and even like the you completed the game screen. And he actually pulled all of the fonts. I don't know how he did this, like if he like pulled it from the game RAM or if he took a bunch of screenshots and edited them.
Sierra游戏，如果你玩过像《国王密使》之类的，嗯，嗯，嗯，很多这种点击式冒险游戏，嗯，我一下子有点想不起来了，但是，嗯，《国王密使》绝对是最受欢迎的，就像《猴岛小英雄》什么的，对吧？《猴岛小英雄》，没错了。所以，嗯，这个人的做法是，他采用了各种各样的，针对那些死亡画面的母题，甚至是“你已通关”的画面。而且他实际上提取了所有的字体。我不知道他是怎么做到的，比如他是从游戏内存中提取的，还是截取了一堆截图并进行了编辑。
But he has the exact font and he has the exact position so that you can replace the message in the death screen with anything you want and it will look you know extremely accurate um and uh and it's amazing for making memes party invitations uh whenever i have meetings now at work i'll just like put that as the meeting invite um it's hilarious uh and oh yeah and so he's he's he's included so many games now there's like mario 64 there's all the zelda games metal gear solid yes yeah metal gear solid system shock doom duke nukem and and all the fonts are perfect railroad tycoon um and i've made some absolutely hilarious memes um this is an absolute riot if you want to set up a meeting uh or an
但他拥有确切的字体，而且拥有确切的位置，这样你就可以用任何你想要的东西替换死亡画面中的消息，而且它看起来，你知道的，极其准确，嗯，而且，它非常适合制作梗图、派对邀请函。现在我在工作中有会议时，我就会把它当作会议邀请放上去，这太搞笑了，哦对了，所以他现在包含了这么多的游戏，有《马里奥64》，有所有的《塞尔达》游戏，《合金装备》，是的，是的，《合金装备》、《系统震荡》、《毁灭战士》、《毁灭公爵》，而且所有的字体都很完美，《铁路大亨》，我制作了一些绝对爆笑的梗图，如果你想安排一个会议，或者
invite to like your birthday or something like that this thing is fantastic i highly recommend it um absolutely hilarious uh definitely check it out. So I was clicking through these, though, and I have two concerns. First of all, I'm not clear how many people I work with who mostly are younger would know many of these titles. And then just in general, even people of any age, you have to be pretty nerdy for some of these. So some of them, like the Zelda ones, I think are a little obvious, or Pokemon, because you can kind of see the people. But of these other ones i'm like i'm not sure i would recognize where this is from
生日派对之类的邀请函，这个东西太棒了，我强烈推荐它，绝对搞笑，一定要去看看。不过，当我点击浏览这些时，我有两个担忧。首先，我不清楚和我一起工作的有多少人（他们大多比较年轻）会知道这些标题中的许多。其次，总的来说，即使是任何年龄的人，对于其中一些游戏，你也必须是个十足的书呆子才行。所以其中一些，比如《塞尔达》的，我觉得有点明显，或者《宝可梦》，因为你可以大致认出那些人物。但对于其他这些，我就觉得，我不确定我是否能认出这是出自哪里的。
yeah there's definitely a lot of esoteric ones um yeah i mean stick to the you know mario 64 yeah you know stick to the heavy hitters um but uh yeah i sent a letter from princess toads to all that my co-worker saw was pretty hilarious you must have been very proud of yourself i was i was like look at you guys i got this stuff figured out people thought i actually made it myself like how long did that take it's like if only you knew the secret uh my tool of the show is a game but this one's actually not a tablet game i feel like i'm i i just i'm falling down the well of not helping people so this one is a console game uh and it's
是的，里面绝对有很多深奥的游戏，嗯，是的，我的意思是，坚持玩那些，你知道的，《马里奥64》，是的，你知道的，坚持玩那些大热门游戏，但是，嗯，是的，我给所有同事发了一封来自桃子公主的信，看起来非常搞笑。你一定为自己感到很骄傲。我当时就想，看看你们这群人，我把这些东西都搞定了。人们以为真的是我自己做的，还问“这花了多长时间？”我就想，如果你们知道其中的秘密就好了。我的本期推荐工具是一款游戏，但这个其实不是平板游戏，我觉得我，我，我只是陷入了无法帮助人们的泥潭，所以这是一个主机游戏，而且它
called overcooked and i thought this was pretty cool i you know i'm late to the game i don't is it a puzzle game i think i've played this uh kind of not really a puzzle game? I think I've played this. Kind of. Not really a puzzle game. But I'm way behind the times. I think there's even like Overcooked 2 now. But I play really old games that are like super cheap because I don't play games that much. And so I got this one. I actually think I got it free on my Xbox one. I have the like Xbox membership someone gifted me.
叫做《胡闹厨房》（Overcooked），我觉得这挺酷的。你知道的，我有点后知后觉，我不知道，这是益智游戏吗？我想我玩过这个，嗯，有点不太算益智游戏？我想我玩过这个。有点算吧。其实不太算益智游戏。但我已经远远落后于时代了。我想现在甚至还有《胡闹厨房2》之类的。但我玩的都是那些超级便宜的真的很老的游戏，因为我不怎么玩游戏。所以我入手了这款。我其实觉得我是从我的Xbox One上免费获得的。我有一个别人赠送的Xbox会员资格。
And so I get like a couple games free a month or whatever and this is one of them and i was like a lot of them are junk um in my opinion but i was playing this one and in this game you are supposed to be uh preparing food for people ignoring the actual like storyline you're preparing food for. And each food has sort of a recipe. And you control a little character and need to get ingredients and then perform some number of steps. So it might be like, get a tomato from the tomato bin, put it on the cutting board, and then chop the tomato and chopping the tomato, you know, takes some amount of time. And then once you chop the tomato, you need to go and put it on a plate. And then need to chop some lettuce put that on a plate and then once the tomato and lettuce
所以我每个月能免费获得几款游戏什么的，这就是其中之一，然后我就觉得，其中很多都是垃圾，依我之见，但我一直在玩这一款，在这款游戏中，你应该为人们准备食物，抛开实际的故事情节不谈，你在为他们准备食物。每种食物都有某种食谱。你控制一个小角色，需要获取食材，然后执行一定数量的步骤。所以它可能是这样的：从番茄箱里拿一个番茄，把它放在案板上，然后切番茄，切番茄，你知道的，需要花一定的时间。然后一旦你切好了番茄，你需要去把它放在盘子里。然后你需要切一些生菜，把它放在盘子里，然后一旦番茄和生菜
are on a plate you can now serve it and there's little cards that tell you you know what you're trying to cook for the current people that are up there and there's some you know optimizations you can do about what you're working on how complex a given dish is and you serve it then it comes back dirty then you need to wash the plate and then put it back, and it's a series of tasks. And some things need to be cooked in like a stock pot as like a soup, and if you leave them on too long, they'll burn. And so the game becomes this sort of like micromanaging
都在盘子里了，你现在就可以端出去了。上面有小卡片告诉你，你知道的，你当前面对的客人们正在尝试烹饪什么，而且有一些，你知道的，关于你正在做什么、给定的菜肴有多复杂的优化，你把它端出去，然后盘子脏着回来了，接着你需要洗盘子，然后把它放回去，这是一系列的任务。有些东西需要在汤锅里像做汤一样煮，如果你把它们留在上面太久，它们就会烧焦。因此，游戏就变成了这种类似于微观管理的模式，
because there are several characters running around, and I originally played it cooperative with other people, and you have to do this sort of hilarious amount of coordination between everyone to be like, I'm going to do the chopping. And you're going to, you know, take the food that's chopped and take it to the plate and serve it and then wash the dish when it comes back. And, you know, trying to divvy up the tasks. And, you know, you're working through the first couple levels and you're feeling pretty good. But then you realize the game starts like throwing a monkey wrench into it. And so they'll have like a path that's only one person wide.
因为有几个角色在到处跑，我最初是和别人合作玩的，你必须在每个人之间进行这种滑稽数量的协调，来像这样：“我要去切菜。然后你去，你知道的，把切好的食物拿过来放到盘子里端出去，然后等盘子回来时把它洗了。”然后，试图分工合作。然后，你通关了前几个关卡，感觉还不错。但随后你意识到游戏开始像这样往里面扔乱七八糟的干扰了。所以他们会有那种只有一个人宽的通道。
And so you can't actually go back and forth. So everyone needs to go like around a racetrack, like counterclockwise. They'll have something where cockroaches will come out from underneath the cabinets and grab your food if you leave it sitting there. They'll like introduce various mechanics where the game world shifts around. People are walking through. You can't always get where you want. Cars that come together and separate. And so all these crazy places you're cooking.
所以你实际上无法来回走动。因此每个人都需要像绕赛车场一样，按逆时针方向走。他们会有这样的设计：蟑螂会从橱柜底下钻出来，如果你把食物放在那里不管，它们就会抢走你的食物。他们会引入各种机制，使游戏世界四处移动。有人走来走去。你并不总能到达你想去的地方。汽车会聚拢又分开。所以在所有这些疯狂的地方你都在做饭。
And I thought it was just really fun. I enjoyed it. I can't say I really beat it. I got stuck. But I had fun. It was a really clever light-hearted thing i'm not sure i would have paid the original price for it whatever it was if it was expensive but um i've seen them on discounts a lot because it's been out for a while but i will say what i've been trying to do and i've i just i can't make my brain work this way is the like i'll call it extreme version because for me it was extreme is you take your controller and it sort of becomes split in in half in the layout so the left half
我觉得这真的很有趣，我很喜欢。我不能说我真的通关了它。我卡关了。但我玩得很开心。这是一个非常聪明、轻松愉快的东西。我不确定我是否会为它支付原价，无论它原来是多少钱，如果它很贵的话，但是，嗯，我看到过很多打折，因为它已经出来一段时间了。但我得说，我一直尝试做的是——而且我就是，我的大脑无法以这种方式运作——就是我称之为极端版本的玩法，因为对我来说这很极端：你拿着你的手柄，它的布局在某种程度上被分成两半，左半部分
controls one person and the right half controls another person oh and so you're you have two people and you're trying to make them work together at the same time in your head like you control two characters and you do it by like controlling each half of the controller uh and and make them run around and do stuff and i yeah that sounds really difficult i feel like i want to be good at doing this but i just like each time i just find one of the guys just standing there doing nothing and yeah that's awesome i'm gonna have to check this out i really love uh party games because uh you know we've been actually playing more um games in the living room where we'll just all
控制一个人，右半部分控制另一个人。哦，所以你有两个人，你试图让它们在你的脑海中同时协同工作——就像你控制两个角色，你通过控制手柄的两半来做到这一点，嗯，让他们到处跑并做事，而我，是的，这听起来真的很困难。我觉得我想擅长做这个，但每次我都发现其中一个家伙只是站在那里什么也不做，而且，是的，这太棒了，我得去看看这个。我真的很喜欢聚会游戏，因为，你知道的，我们实际上已经在客厅里玩了更多，嗯，游戏，我们会全部
gather around the tv yeah and so you know games especially games where you it sounds like this is one where you know at least on the earlier levels you could have one person who maybe isn't as efficient as everyone else definitely still kind of play it and have fun. Yeah. And if you play on like higher player counts too, I think we've played like three or four people. Yeah. And yeah, if one person is messing,
聚集在电视机周围，是的，所以，你知道的游戏，尤其是那种你——听起来这是一款游戏，你知道的，至少在早期的关卡中，你可以有一个可能不像其他人那么高效的人，绝对还能一起玩并且玩得很开心。是的。如果你玩更高的玩家数量的话，我想我们玩过三四个人。是的。而且，是的，如果一个人搞砸了，
it's not the end of world, you might not get a high score, you know, you're not gonna beat the end levels, but yeah, you can definitely have fun. It's hilarious. And people are like yelling at each other,
这不是世界末日，你可能拿不到高分，你知道的，你通不了最后的关卡，但，是的，你绝对可以玩得很开心。这太搞笑了。人们会互相大喊大叫，
like get out of my way. No, I'm doing that. Well, you weren't. That sounds awesome. Anyways, and that's available for like a lot of consoles,
比如“别挡我的路”。“不，我在做那个。”“好吧，你刚才没做。”这听起来太棒了。总之，这适用于很多主机，
like I think switch the xbox one playstation 4 so if you have a current gen console i'm pretty sure it's available cool man yeah i'll totally check that out all right on to typescript um i've been using a lot of typescript lately i've been building a little front end for this analysis, this data analysis pipeline that I've been building. And it's really nice, actually. The tooling is great. And so we'll kind of recap. To understand TypeScript, you have to really understand typing, right? Otherwise, the appeal is just lost, right?
比如我觉得Switch、Xbox One、PlayStation 4都有，所以如果你有当代的机器，我非常确定它是可以玩的。酷，伙计，是的，我完全会去看看那个。好吧，接下来是TypeScript。我最近一直在使用很多TypeScript，我一直在为我正在构建的这个分析、这个数据分析流水线构建一个小的前端。而且它真的很不错，实际上。工具链很棒。所以我们来回顾一下。要理解TypeScript，你必须真正理解类型，对吧？否则它的吸引力就全无了，对吧？
So, yeah, basically, and I've talked about this before, and actually I've gotten a lot of flack for this. This might be the thing that I get the most hate mail about in the history of us doing this show, but I'm just not a big fan of statically typed languages. I'm sorry, dynamically typed languages oh man you're about to get me on you oh man yeah i know i'm not a big fan of like uh we'll call it like i guess pure python i don't know what you want to call it um or javascript or things like that and basically
所以，是的，基本上，我之前也谈到过这个，实际上我为此受到了很多批评。这可能是我在我们做这个节目的历史中获得最多仇恨邮件的事情，但我只是不太喜欢静态类型语言。对不起，是动态类型语言，哦天哪，你这是要抓住我的把柄啊，哦天哪，是的，我知道我不太喜欢，嗯，我们称之为，我猜是纯Python，我不知道你想怎么称呼它，嗯，或者JavaScript之类的事情，基本上
it just kind of falls apart in many different ways um now you know just a caveat so python 3 has the typing module which everyone should be using um and now javascript has has typescript and they've had coffee script and other things in the past it seems like typescript is sort of uh has come to sort of dominate um but but all of these things are you know and also there's mypy which was what you could use in Python before Python 3 but all of these things are basically transpilers so what they do is if you don't put the type in Python it's not going to error like it would in C like in C you can't just say x equals 3. It's going to blow up.
它在许多不同的方面都会崩溃，嗯。现在，你知道的，只是一个警告——所以Python 3有类型模块，每个人都应该使用它，嗯，现在JavaScript有了TypeScript，过去他们有过CoffeeScript和其他东西。看起来TypeScript似乎已经，嗯，占据了主导地位，但是，但是所有这些东西都是，你知道的，还有Mypy，这是你在Python 3之前可以在Python中使用的东西，但所有这些东西基本上都是转译器。所以它们的作用是，如果你不在Python中加入类型，它不会像在C语言中那样报错——就像在C语言中，你不能只是说x等于3。它会崩溃的。
But in Python, even with the typing support, you can still say x equals 3. Nothing's going to stop you unless you have like a linter that's really strict. But you don't get a compile error or anything like that. But you can say, well if you say x equals 3, it's going to assume that x is an integer. So then if your next line is x equals dog, then you actually will get a warning. It'll say, hey, you just said x equals a 3, and now you're saying it's a dog. That just seems a little shady.
但在Python中，即使有了类型支持，你仍然可以写x等于3。没有什么能阻止你，除非你有一个非常严格的代码检查工具（linter）。但你不会得到编译错误或类似的东西。不过你可以说，好吧，如果你说x等于3，它会假设x是一个整数。所以如果你的下一行是x等于狗，那么你实际上会得到一个警告。它会说，嘿，你刚才说x等于一个3，现在你又说它是一只狗。这看起来有点可疑。
You could do x colon any equals 3, and now you're telling the type system, leave me alone. Like you're saying, I want x to be anything. Don't correct me. You can do that. But if you do, you know, x equals three, and then later on, you pass x into a function. And that person who wrote that function, let's say a week later, changes that function to now take strings instead of integers. That's going to cause an error right away. So it's not like that person will make that change. And then the next time you deploy version 10 of your system, it just blows up or your unit tests kind of blow up in some weird way. The type system is going to catch that immediately
你可以写x冒号any等于3，现在你是在告诉类型系统：别烦我。就像你在说，我希望x可以是任何东西。不要纠正我。你可以这么做。但如果你这样做了，你知道的，x等于3，然后稍后，你把x传递给一个函数。而编写该函数的人，比方说一周后，将该函数修改为现在接受字符串而不是整数。这会立即导致错误。所以这不像那个人会做出那个改变，然后当你下一次部署系统的第10版时，它就崩溃了，或者你的单元测试以某种奇怪的方式崩溃了。类型系统会立即捕捉到这一点，
and tell that person who's making that change, hey, buddy, someone's passing in an integer to this. So if you're going to make that change and say that's going to be a string, then we need to reconcile that. And actually, I would say even to this day, the majority of the errors get caught in this way. So the majority of the time, you know, I don't actually have to run something because I've caught some error right away and I can just go in and fix it. And when I run things, the chance that they're successful goes way up.
并告诉那个做出修改的人：嘿，伙计，有人正在向这个函数传入一个整数。所以如果你要做出那个修改并说它将是一个字符串，那么我们需要进行协调。而且实际上，我可以说直到今天，大部分错误都是通过这种方式被捕获的。所以在绝大多数情况下，你知道的，我实际上不必运行某些东西，因为我已经立刻捕获了某个错误，我可以直接进去修复它。而当我运行程序时，它们成功的几率会大大增加。
And Patrick, I think you mostly use statically typed languages, right? Do you do a lot of dynamically typed languages? No, I don't. Not that I avoid them. I just, I avoid them. I thought you did Scala now or no? No. So I've done, like dabbled in various of them, but I've not ever spent much time in them.
帕特里克，我想你主要使用静态类型语言，对吧？你经常使用动态类型语言吗？不，我没有。倒不是说我刻意避开它们。只是，我避开它们。我以为你现在用Scala或者没有？没有。所以我有过，涉猎过其中各种语言，但我从没花太多时间在它们上面。
So I currently I've been doing some Python stuff. But as you point out, it was been mostly mostly python 2 stuff so it's not with types and the things you're pointing out are the issues i run into which is people don't and in python sometimes people do it intentionally like change the type of a variable so in some places it's one thing and in some places is another and use that for sort of code flow but that's to me is like really confusing uh yeah hard to follow with that so just to i mean it is a hassle to set up so not everyone has this set up but with python 2 you can use my pi and the way it actually works it's it's a little frustrating it's done with comments so you actually have to do the you know the um you have to do like a you know a double
所以我目前一直在做一些Python相关的事情。但正如你所指出的，它大部分、大部分都是Python 2的东西，所以它没有类型，而你指出的那些正是令我头疼的问题，也就是人们没有——在Python中，有时人们是有意这样做的——改变一个变量的类型，所以在某些地方它是一种类型，在另一些地方是另一种类型，并用它来做某种代码流，但对我来说这真的很让人困惑，嗯，很难跟上。所以只是为了——我的意思是，设置起来确实很麻烦，所以并不是每个人都做了这个设置，但对于Python 2，你可以使用Mypy，它实际的运作方式，它有点令人沮丧，它是通过注释完成的，所以你实际上必须做，你知道的，嗯，你必须做一个，你知道的，双
quote integer double quote um and you do that i think it's after the variable name and then my pie just strips out all those comments and after it does the type checking and it's definitely not as nice as typing but it runs uh basically this transpiling this comp compiling step. That's right. So MyPy will strip out all of those things that you wrote, and along the way it will check the types. And that's exactly what TypeScript does as well. So you're putting all of these things that aren't valid JavaScript. Like JavaScript doesn't expect you to put x colon int equals three. It's not expecting that.
引号integer双引号，你这样做，我记得是在变量名之后，然后Mypy就会在进行类型检查后剥离掉所有这些注释，它肯定没有原生类型那么好，但它运行的是，基本上是这种转译、这种编译步骤。没错。所以Mypy会剥离掉你写的所有那些东西，并在过程中检查类型。这正是TypeScript也在做的事情。所以你放入所有这些不合法的JavaScript代码。就像JavaScript不希望你写出x冒号int等于3一样。它不期望这样。
So what TypeScript does is after it's not expecting that um so what typescript does is it you know after it's done checking everything it has to go through and delete all of that um extra code and i think it's you know it's it's not even like that would be kind of frustrating for them to do so they don't actually do that what they do is they they compile the code down i believe to some intermediate language and then decompile it um but um one thing they do is they create what's called a source map which is something that i don't think we've talked about ever on the show but a source map is basically um when you're compiling code either to you know machine language or assembly code thing, you want to kind of keep track of what line of source code contributed to what lines of whatever it is downstream.
所以TypeScript的做法是，在它不期望这样之后，嗯，所以TypeScript的做法是，你知道的，在它完成所有检查之后，它必须遍历并删除所有这些，嗯，额外的代码，而且我觉得这，这，甚至对他们来说也会有点令人沮丧，所以他们实际上不那样做，他们做的是，我相信他们把代码编译成某种中间语言，然后再进行反编译，但是，嗯，他们做的一件事是创建了所谓的“源映射”（source map），这是我认为我们在节目中从未谈论过的事情，但源映射基本上是，
So in the case of TypeScript, it's like what line of TypeScript turned into this section could be part of a line, it could be multiple lines, but this section of JavaScript. And that's a source map. And so TypeScript will generate a source map. So when you have an error in of JavaScript, and that's a source map. And so TypeScript will generate a
当你把代码编译成机器语言或汇编语言之类的东西时，你会想要跟踪哪一行源代码贡献了下游的哪几行代码。所以在TypeScript的情况下，就像是哪一行的TypeScript变成了这一部分——它可以是一行的一部分，也可以是多行——但这部分的JavaScript。这就是源映射。所以TypeScript会生成一个源映射。所以当你的JavaScript中出现错误时，
source map. So, you know, when you have an error in your JavaScript, it's going to be very hard to look at that code and see what's going on, because you didn't write it, it was generated by this TypeScript compiler, right? So the source, along with some browser plugins and things like that, will actually make it so that when you get an error you see the error in typescript in your typescript file and and my pi has something similar for python so yeah i think the that is an option have you thought about doing that like running my pi no i didn't know that was a thing until three minutes ago okay yeah i definitely recommend it i mean well actually why aren't you on python 3
由于有源映射，你知道的，当你代码中的JavaScript出现错误时，要看着那段代码并弄清楚发生了什么会非常困难，因为那不是你写的，它是这个TypeScript编译器生成的，对吧？所以源码，连同一些浏览器插件之类的东西，实际上会使得当你遇到错误时，你会在你的TypeScript文件中看到那个错误。而Mypy对Python也有类似的东西。所以，是的，我认为这是一个选项。你有没有考虑过那样做——运行Mypy？不，在三分钟前我都不知道有这回事。好吧，是的，我绝对推荐它，我的意思是，话说回来，为什么你不用Python 3呢？
don't is there like a really no reason no no no when i said which python and then i said python dash dash version and it told me it was python 2 oh okay all right i think you have to do well depends on the os but uh um if you're on mac you would have to brew install python 3 or use anaconda or one of those distributions yeah but uh but yeah so but i mean i do i do agree with your your preference for static typing because i feel one of the things is when you get in someone else's code and that's the the crazy thing is you might have an intuition for oh this thing is supposed to be a you know this type or that type but when other people read it especially code that isn't the
等一下，难道没有理由吗？不不不，当我说了哪个Python，然后我输入了 python dash dash version，它告诉我是Python 2，哦好吧，好吧，我觉得你得，这取决于操作系统，但是呃，如果你用的是Mac，你得用brew install python 3或者用Anaconda之类的发行版。是的，但是，是的，所以，但我确实同意你对静态类型的偏好，因为我觉得其中一点是，当你接手别人的代码时，最疯狂的事情是，你可能会有一种直觉，哦，这个东西应该是一个，你知道的，这种类型或那种类型，但当其他人阅读它时，尤其是当代码不是那种
middle or is is in the middle so not like the highest level code but code in the middle or the bottom it becomes very unclear and easy to lose track of what types. So if you have code that's supposed to sort of which a lot of code ends up being passed stuff around or do some transformations, it's very difficult to tell what the type can be. And for someone coming in and trying to make something they're more efficient, or to run better, it can be very difficult to tell what all all especially if you know like jason was pointing out like this type any makes it very difficult to know that you're doing is safe across all the kinds of types that can be passed in yep and then you have to handle optional as well so like by default in python anything can be none at any time and what's even worse is if a function takes um well it gets there's actually
处于中间层或者说处于中间的代码，不是最高层的代码，而是中间或底层的代码，就会变得非常不明确，很容易搞不清具体是什么类型。所以，如果你有一些代码，它的作用是，很多代码最终都是把一些东西传来传去或者做一些转换，那就很难看出它的类型到底是什么。对于一个新来的人，想要让代码更高效或者运行得更好，这会非常困难，特别是如果你知道，就像Jason指出的那样，这种any类型使得你很难知道你的操作在所有可能传入的类型中都是安全的。是的，然后你还得处理可选类型，所以比如在Python中，默认情况下任何东西在任何时候都可以是none，更糟糕的是，如果一个函数接收呃，其实这里有
some checks for this but depending on the language i think in javascript if a function in python if a function takes three arguments and you pass it two i think it'll error which is good um in javascript i think it just fills the rest with undefined or nulls or something like that so so if someone adds an option to a function and they're expecting an option to be able to say true or false and you haven't updated all of the different call sites, they'll start getting undefined. And so what happens is people have to guard against that.
一些针对这个的检查，但根据语言的不同，我想在JavaScript中，如果Python里的一个函数需要三个参数而你传了两个，我想它会报错，这很好。嗯，在JavaScript中，我想它只是把剩下的用undefined或null或者类似的东西填补。所以，如果有人给函数加了一个选项，他们希望这个选项能说true或false，而你没有更新所有不同的调用点，它们就会开始得到undefined。所以发生的情况是，人们必须防范这种情况。
It just makes the code a total nightmare. With TypeScript, unless you say explicitly, and I think the way it works in TypeScript is you put a question mark in front of the type. So if you do x colon question mark int, then that x could be equal to null or undefined. But if you just do x colon int, it has to be a number.
这会让代码变成一场彻头彻尾的噩梦。使用TypeScript时，除非你显式声明，而且我认为TypeScript的工作方式是在类型前面加一个问号。所以如果你写 x 冒号 问号 int，那么那个 x 就可以等于 null 或 undefined。但如果你只是写 x 冒号 int，它必须是一个数字。
If you do x colon int equals null, you'll get an error. And so what that means is by default, everything needs to exist. And which is actually really, really nice. You know, people think that, you know, they're used to like C pointers and C++ pointers, which are null and become allocated and things like that. And in that world, it kind of makes sense.
如果你写 x 冒号 int 等于 null，你会得到一个错误。这意味着默认情况下，所有东西都是必须存在的。这其实真的非常非常棒。你知道，人们认为，他们习惯了像C指针和C++指针，它们是null，然后被分配内存等等。在那个世界里，这倒有点道理。
Like, especially like, oh, I've destroyed this object. All of its members should now be null or undefined or something right but when you go to these higher level languages in general you really don't need a lot of things to be null um i mean there might be some things that are sort of optional based on the context and things like that but it's nothing compared to what you need when you're manipulating memory at the level of C or C++. So by default, having null turned off is actually a really nice feature. So there's some disadvantages. It's not like anything is over bullet. One of the big disadvantages for TypeScript is you actually need to install two packages for every package.
特别是像，哦，我已经销毁了这个对象。它的所有成员现在都应该是null或undefined之类的。但当你转向这些更高阶的语言时，一般来说，你真的不需要那么多东西都是null。嗯，可能有些东西根据上下文是可选的之类的，但这与你在C或C++级别操作内存时所需的东西相比根本不算什么。所以默认情况下关闭null其实是一个非常棒的功能。当然也有一些缺点。它不是万灵药。TypeScript的一个大缺点是，你实际上需要为每个包安装两个包。
So for example, if you typically say, yarn install jQuery, now you also have to yarn install typing jQuery, which is just a file that gives you all the types. So a lot of these systems, they're either written in pure JavaScript or they don't want to have to force everyone to use typescript and so for that reason um the way they get around that is they have a separate repository for all the types which is pretty weird i mean it's just it's this file that just has
所以例如，如果你通常说 yarn install jQuery，现在你还得 yarn install typing jQuery，这只是一个给你提供所有类型的文件的包。因此，许多这些系统，它们要么是用纯JavaScript编写的，要么是不想强迫每个人都使用TypeScript，所以出于这个原因，他们绕过这个限制的方法是为所有类型单独建立一个代码库，这挺奇怪的，也就是说它只是这样一个文件，里面全是
um just lists and lists and lists of types and then their location. And it must be programmatically generated because it just looks too difficult to write by hand. But you have to kind of keep that in mind. If you don't install the typing, then the IDE will kind of complain. And you have to either go and turn that off or go find the typing. So that whole process could be pretty frustrating. You know, another thing is it takes time. So with JavaScript, you just run it. With TypeScript, you have to now do this process of turning it into JavaScript.
各种类型的列表以及它们的位置。它一定是以编程方式生成的，因为看起来太难手写了。但你必须记住这一点。如果你不安装类型定义，IDE就会抱怨。你要么得去把它关掉，要么得去找到类型定义。所以整个过程可能会相当令人沮丧。你知道，另一件事是它需要时间。对于JavaScript，你直接运行就行。对于TypeScript，你现在必须经历把它转译成JavaScript的过程。
Although most computers now are so fast, it doesn't really matter. And it makes the deployment more complex. If it's JavaScript, you could just rsync the code over to your web server most people want to run it through some type of packer minifier or something like that but those run extremely quickly i mean the simplest minifier would just cat all the files together which could be done like almost instantly um now you've added this compilation step. And so you typically, there is actually a program called TSC, Transcript Compiler.
尽管现在的计算机都太快了，这其实无所谓。而且这让部署变得更复杂。如果是JavaScript，你大可以将代码rsync到你的网页服务器上。大多数人希望通过某种打包器、混淆器或类似的东西来运行它，但那些运行速度极快。最简单的混淆器就是把所有文件连接在一起，这几乎可以瞬间完成。现在你加上了这个编译步骤。所以通常，实际上有一个叫做TSC（TypeScript编译器）的程序。
And you could call that on all of your transcript files and then concatenate all these JavaScript files together by hand. But in practice, nobody really does that. In practice, people do, they use Babel or Webpack. There's an extension called Webpack dash TS. But all of these things just are complicated. Like, I mean, it's going to take some serious setup time to get, you know, kind of the right flow up and running. And TypeScript is still
你可以在所有的TypeScript文件上调用它，然后手动将这些JavaScript文件连接在一起。但在实践中，没有人真的这样做。在实践中，人们使用的是Babel或Webpack。有一个扩展叫做Webpack dash TS。但所有这些事情都很复杂。我的意思是，这需要一些认真的设置时间来建立和运行正确的流程。而且TypeScript仍然
relatively new. So there's going to be some hiccups and things like that along the way. But with all that said, it's totally, totally worth it. I really enjoy the system that I have up and running right now. If you use an IDE, it gets even better. So if you use, for example, Visual Studio Code or Sublime with the TypeScript plugin, these IDEs are actually communicating back and forth between the TypeScript plugin. These IDs are actually communicating back and forth between the TypeScript compiler. And so, you know, they'll give you errors right away. They're also sort of plugged into the types of the objects. So if you do, you know, if you pass
相对较新。所以一路上会有些小波折之类的。但话虽如此，它绝对、绝对是值得的。我真的很喜欢我目前搭建和运行的系统。如果你使用IDE，体验会更好。所以如果你使用，例如Visual Studio Code或带有TypeScript插件的Sublime，这些IDE实际上在与TypeScript插件进行双向通信。这些IDE实际上在与TypeScript编译器进行双向通信。
in an X to another function, that function, you do do x dot you're going to get the functions on int you know it's going to know that it's going to do the type inferencing and things like that for you so definitely you know IDE really doubles the advantage of TypeScript but even if you're just using Emacs
所以，你知道，它们会立即给你报错。它们还接入了对象的类型。所以如果你把一个X传给另一个函数，那个函数，你输入x点，你就会得到int上的函数，你知道，它会知道，它会为你做类型推断之类的事情。所以绝对地，IDE确实将TypeScript的优势翻倍了，但即使你只是在使用Emacs，
TypeScript is a huge savings and you know it works with Flywheel and these other Emacs plugins. So overall, I highly recommend it. Getting time to actually learn to do front end is, is still on my list. But now that, you know, I was talking to Jason before, I mean, I, I previously was like, oh, CoffeeScript, this seems like a way for me to ease into not having to deal with the
TypeScript也能带来巨大的节省，而且你知道，它与Flywheel和其他Emacs插件兼容。总的来说，我强烈推荐它。抽出时间真正学习前端开发仍然在我的日程表上。但现在，你知道的，我之前跟Jason谈过，我的意思是，我以前觉得，哦，CoffeeScript，这似乎是我不用去应付
craziness of no types, but I've been informed it's dead. So, and it's dead. So... And it's gone. Yeah, I would recommend it. I mean, it took me a while, definitely, to get up to speed. It's been years since I built a website. And everything I'd built up until now
无类型带来的疯狂的一种捷径，但我被告知它已经死了。所以，它已经死了。所以……它已经不在了。是的，我会推荐它。我的意思是，我确实花了一段时间才赶上进度。我已经好几年没建过网站了。到目前为止我构建的一切
is with pure JavaScript. This is my first time doing TypeScript. So there's definitely a learning curve, but it's really nice once you get it up and running. But I think it sounds like the first thing you need to do is get on Python 3.
都是用纯JavaScript。这是我第一次使用TypeScript。所以绝对有一个学习曲线，但一旦你把它搭建并运行起来，感觉真的很棒。但我觉得听起来你首先要做的是用上Python 3。
I shouldn't have admitted that. Apparently this is a bad thing now. It's end of life. We didn't talk about that, did we? But yeah. That's right. That's right. When is that? Do you know? I don't know. Sometimes. Yeah, so I'll fill in while you're looking. Basically,
我不该承认这一点的。显然现在这是一件坏事。它已经停止支持了。我们没聊过这个，对吧？但确实如此。没错。没错。那是什么时候？你知道吗？我不知道。有时候吧。好吧，在你查的时候我来补充一下。基本上，
Python... The backstory here is a little bit interesting. They created Python 3, and Python 3 is not backwards compatible. And this is pretty mind-blowing.
Python……这里的背景故事有点意思。他们创造了Python 3，而Python 3是不向下兼容的。这真的是太震撼了。
A lot of people don't know this, but the biggest reason why it's not backwards compatible. And this is pretty mind blowing. A lot of people don't know this, but the biggest reason why it's not backwards compatible is the way strings are handled. And anyone who's ever done Unicode or internationalization in Python 2 knows what a total disaster it is. Python 2 strings were kind of designed to be single byte strings that kind of comes from the c days where it's like you'd have a string of four characters and it just meant kind of four bytes um the issue is you know then they needed to support multi-byte characters for unicode so they created a unicode type and it just created total havoc because, again, without type safety, people would pass in Unicode types to functions that were expecting string types.
很多人不知道这一点，但它不向下兼容的最大原因，这真的是太震撼了。很多人不知道这一点，但它不向下兼容的最大原因处理字符串的方式。任何在Python中做过Unicode或国际化的人都知道这是多么彻底的一场灾难。Python 2的字符串在设计上有点像单字节字符串，这有点源于C语言的时代，那时你有一个由四个字符组成的字符串，它基本上就意味着四个字节。问题在于，你知道，后来他们需要为Unicode支持多字节字符，所以他们创造了一种Unicode类型，这就造成了彻底的混乱，因为，再次强调，在没有类型安全的情况下，人们会把Unicode类型传给期望接收字符串类型的函数。
And some of the functions wouldn't work the way they expected. So then Python got really strict about that. And if you tried to run string functions on the Unicode type, Python would just error. They just became very aggressive about failing instead of trying to do the right thing as a defense mechanism for the weak typing. Python 3 fixes all of that by just deleting the string type and renaming the Unicode type string. And that is awesome. But it's a pretty devastating change.
而有些函数并没有按他们预期的那样工作。于是Python开始在这方面变得非常严格。如果你试图在Unicode类型上运行字符串函数，Python就会直接报错。作为弱类型的一种防范机制，它们变得对失败非常积极，而不是试图去做正确的事情。Python 3通过直接删除字符串类型并将Unicode类型重命名为字符串来解决所有这些问题。这太棒了。但这是一个相当毁灭性的改变。
Like almost every app uses a string. So it caused a lot of drama. There's times, there's a whole, there's years where people are saying Py3 is just going to die, things like that. But the Unicode thing is super frustrating and eventually it kind of went over. January 1st, 2020.
几乎每个应用都会用到字符串。所以这引起了很多戏剧性事件。有一段时间，有好几年人们都在说Py3要完蛋了之类的话。但Unicode这事超级烦人，不过最终它还是普及开了。2020年1月1日，
Python 2.7 loses its support. That's pretty soon. Or at least that's according to pythonclock.org in 10 months. Oh, pythonclock.org. It's just a clock that counts down the death of Python. Yes. Python 2.
Python 2.7将失去支持。那很快了。或者至少根据 pythonclock.org 的说法，还有10个月。哦，pythonclock.org。这只是一个倒计时Python死亡的时钟。是的。Python 2。
Amazing. Yeah, right. Very cool. Well, yeah, definitely switch to Python 3. Use the typing module. It will save you a lot of headache. That was a good end to our TypeScript episode. That's right.
太神奇了。是的，没错。非常酷。好吧，是的，绝对要切换到Python 3。使用typing模块。这会为你省去很多头疼的事。我们这期关于TypeScript的节目以一个美好的结尾收场。没错。
Use typing. Typing is great. And, you know, it's a short month, so we'll keep the TypeScript topic relatively short. But you should all be fantastic. You know, it's a short month, so we'll keep the TypeScript topic relatively short. But you should all be fantastic. You can use it for browser or server. So it actually supports both. So I have it set up right now, which you can see in that news article I posted.
使用typing。Typing太棒了。而且，你知道，这是一个短暂的月份，所以我们会把TypeScript这个话题保持得相对简短。但你们所有人都应该很棒。你知道，这是一个短暂的月份，所以我们会把TypeScript这个话题保持得相对简短。但你们所有人都应该很棒。你可以把它用于浏览器或服务器。所以它实际上两者都支持。所以我现在把它设置好了，正如你在我发布的那个新闻文章中看到的。
It actually has TypeScript on both with the hot reloading. So it's the hotness. Check it out. All right. Until next time. See you later. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed
它实际上在两端都配备了TypeScript以及热重载。所以这很热门。去看看吧。好的。直到下次。再见。片头曲是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 的发行
under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
遵循 Creative Commons 署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混编、改编，但你必须注明署名，并且以相同方式共享。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。